I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello! Hey, happy New Year.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事，带您深入了解《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士 6.0》。你好！嘿，新年快乐。
Happy 2020. 2026, lady. We have a New Year's resolution. We do. Should we share it? Yes, this is a shared BFF, not only just in our work life, but in our home life, shared New Year's resolution. I've never had a shared New Year's resolution before. Me either.
2020年快乐。女士，2026年了。我们有一个新年愿景。我们确实有。我们要分享吗？是的，这是一个共同的闺蜜愿景，不仅在我们的工作生活中，也在我们的家庭生活中，这是我们共同的新年愿景。我以前从未有过共同的新月愿景。我也没有。
I highly recommend it because I feel like we're going to hold each other accountable. I do too. Okay, say what it is. It's called get off the hamster wheel. That's right. Because we work from home, and I've talked to a lot of people who manage businesses from home, you can very easily always be working or always be doing a chore. It's like, oh, I'm just going to throw this laundry in before I get on this Zoom.
我强烈推荐它，因为我觉得我们能互相监督。我也这么觉得。好吧，说说是什么吧。它叫“跳出仓鼠轮”。没错。因为我们在家工作，而且我和许多在家管理业务的人聊过，你很容易就会一直工作或者一直做家务。这就好像，哦，我上Zoom之前先把这堆衣服洗了。
Yeah. Or it's Saturday. So I'm just going to bang out a couple hours of work here in the morning. Yeah. But what happens is you were saying, Ang, it's like all of a sudden you wake up and you're like, I have worked 20 days in a row without a full day off. Yeah, because you just like, you know, you just scoge little things in every day. but what you are saying, and I so agree, is that let's say you're like, oh, you know, it's
对。或者今天是星期六。所以我早上就在这里花几个小时把工作赶完。对。但发生的情况就像你说的，安吉，你会突然醒来，心想：我已经连续工作20天没有完整休假了。对，因为你只是，你知道，每天偷偷做一点小事。但正如你所说，我也非常赞同，假设你会想：哦，你知道的，今天是
Saturday morning. I'm going to do a few hours of work, but then it stays with you. All day. All day. So then you're like, hmm, I wonder if Jenna saw that email. And I'm like, no, no, no, turn that part of my brain off. Yeah. So I am committed to you, Jenna, that we are going to take two days off every week. Yes, weekends off. Yes. We're getting off the hamster wheel for a full decompress. And this was inspired by our break, where we took a full week off for our break. Yeah. And we were like, oh, wow. That felt good. Feels good. Yeah. So we're getting off the wheel. And then I want to get us a gift that I was telling Jenna. I'm sure you're going to be like, I don't want it. I want to get on a pillow or like some kind of embroidery, a little hamster on a
星期六早晨。我要工作几个小时，但这种状态会一直伴随着你。一整天。一整天。所以你会想：嗯，不知道詹娜有没有看到那封邮件。然后我会想：不，不，不，把大脑的那一部分关掉。是的。所以我向你承诺，詹娜，我们每周都要休假两天。是的，周末休息。是的。我们要跳出仓鼠轮，彻底放松一下。这是我们的假期给我们的启发，我们在假期里整整休息了一周。对。然后我们觉得：哦，哇。感觉真好。感觉真好。对。所以我们要跳出这个轮子。然后我想给我们买一件礼物，我跟詹娜说过。我确信你会觉得：我才不要。我想买一个枕头，或者某种刺绣，上面绣着一只小仓鼠在
wheel with a big X across it. Why would I not want that? I want that. I want it to be like a visual reminder because it's easy to climb on that wheel. It is, right? Yes. All right. Shared New Year's resolution. Well, listen, we are excited to be back. We're excited to be breaking down all of the episodes of the paper in the new year.
轮子里，中间画着一个大大的叉。我为什么不要这个？我想要。我希望它能作为一个视觉提醒，因为人很容易又爬回那个轮子里。确实是这样，对吧？是的。好了。共同的新年愿景。听着，我们很高兴能回归。我们很高兴能在新的一年里剖析《The Paper》的所有剧集。
But we have a new, what would you call it? More new things. We have a new format. Oh, yes. For the new year. We are going to kick off each episode with a chit-chat suggestion from one of you. Yeah, we're having so much fun. you guys have sent us really great topics.
但我们有一个新的，你会怎么称呼它？更多的新事物。我们有了一个新形式。哦，是的。为了迎接新年。我们每集节目都将由你们其中一位提出的闲聊建议来开场。对，我们玩得很开心。你们给我们发来了非常棒的话题。
So let's kick off this episode with a suggestion from Stephanie A in San Diego, California. Hi, office ladies. This is Stephanie in San Diego, California, originally from Ohio. Go, Buckeyes. My question for you is, where is the worst place you have been stuck for a long time? Looking forward to hearing the answers. I knew mine right away. Same.
所以让我们以来自加利福尼亚州圣迭戈的斯蒂芬妮·A的建议来开启这一集吧。嗨，办公室女士们。我是来自加利福尼亚州圣迭戈的斯蒂芬妮，原本来自俄亥俄州。加油，七叶树队。我的问题是：你们去过的最糟糕、被困了很久的地方是哪里？非常期待听到答案。我一下子就知道我的答案是什么了。我也是。
Go. You go. go? Yeah, you go. Mine's kind of long. Mine's also long. Oh, no. These were clearly core memories for us. Stephanie, great question. Many, many, many years ago, when I was still married to James, we received a Christmas gift. Okay. And it was to go on an outing on a shark boat. Oh my gosh. What's a shark boat? You get on a boat. somewhere in like the Long Beach Harbor. Okay. And you go out to sea and then you see sharks, I guess.
开始。你先。你先？对，你先。我的有点长。我的也很长。哦，不。这些显然是我们刻骨铭心的记忆。斯蒂芬妮，好问题。很多很多年前，当我还没和詹姆斯离婚时，我们收到了一份圣诞礼物。好吧。是一次鲨鱼船游玩之旅。哦天哪。什么是鲨鱼船？你上了一艘船。在类似长滩港口的地方。好吧。然后你出海，接着就能看到鲨鱼，我想是的。
Like they swim up by the boat? I think you go down in a cage. No. And then you can see sharks. Jenna. Let me tell you what happened, though. We loaded onto the boat with enthusiasm. And we got out, oh, we were 10.
就像它们会游到船边一样？我想你是要进到一个笼子里。没有。然后你就能看到鲨鱼。詹娜。不过，让我告诉你发生了什么。我们满怀热情地上了船。然后我们出发了，哦，我们在船上呆了10
minutes on this boat, I got so, so seasick, like so seasick that I spent the whole trip inside the little galley of the boat. Oh, no. Curled up under the dining table. There was no dramamine. There were no options. It was just me and my personal grit. And just muscling through it. That is a miserable feeling, that kind of nausea, that rocking back and forth. Yes. Because when you, get out there, they stop the boat. And so you're just rocking for hours, hours. And my kids know about the shark boat experience because I have said, like, as an anecdote, if I can survive the shark boat, I can survive anything.
分钟，我就晕船得厉害，晕得厉害到我整个行程都待在船上的那个小厨房里。哦，不。蜷缩在餐桌底下。没有茶苯海明晕车药。没有任何选择。只有我和我个人的毅力。硬挺过去的。那种感觉太痛苦了，那种恶心感，那种前后摇晃。是的。因为当你到达那里时，他们会停船。所以你就得摇晃好几个小时，几个小时。我的孩子们都知道鲨鱼船的经历，因为我曾把这当作一个轶事说：如果我能在鲨鱼船上活下来，我就能挺过任何事情。
And when I was getting chemo and I said that I didn't feel good, my kids said, is it worse than the shark boat? Oh. Like, that's how, like, how often. the shark boat was. And I texted James about it. I said, do you mind if I tell the shark boat? And also, I can't remember. Did you enjoy the shark boat? Yeah, did he go in the cage? He, no, he didn't. He wrote me and he said, and he said, I could quote him. He said, quote, it was one of the worst days of my life. Oh, no. He said, I was miserable. I didn't throw up like nearly everyone else around me.
当我在进行化疗并说我感觉不舒服时，我的孩子们说：有鲨鱼船那么糟糕吗？哦。就像是，看鲨鱼船的频率有多高。我为此给詹姆斯发了短信。我说：你介意我讲讲鲨鱼船的事吗？另外，我不记得了。你喜欢鲨鱼船吗？对，他进笼子了吗？他，没有，他没进。他回信对我说，他说我可以引用他的话。他说，原话是：那是我一生中最糟糕的日子之一。哦，不。他说：我痛苦极了。我没有像周围几乎所有人那样呕吐。
And then I asked him about the cage. I said, did you see any sharks? I wouldn't know. I spent the whole trip under the table. He said, they brought out a shark that was about nine inches long, and I pet it, and I felt terrible for it. That's the only fucking shark we saw. Worst day of my life. Oh, that's Josh's worst nightmare.
然后我问他关于笼子的事。我说：你看到鲨鱼了吗？我怎么会知道。我整个行程都待在桌子底下。他说：他们带出了一条大约九英寸长的鲨鱼，我摸了摸它，我觉得它太可怜了。那是我们看到的唯一一条他妈的鲨鱼。我一生中最糟糕的一天。哦，那是乔什的终极噩梦。
He gets so motion sick. He can't go on a boat. I have swim with sharks. You know that, though. Yes. Yeah. but they weren't like big scary sharks and they were well fed. And Rashida and I swam with them. I mean, it sounds like the only shark that James saw was about the size of a large fish.
他极其容易晕动症。他根本坐不了船。我和鲨鱼一起游过泳。不过你知道那个。是的。是的。但它们不是那种可怕的大鲨鱼，而且它们被喂得很饱。拉希达和我跟它们一起游过泳。我的意思是，听起来詹姆斯看到的唯一一条鲨鱼也就大鱼那么大。
Oh, no. Nine inches. I mean. That's, and you guys, it was all day on that boat. That's horrible. Yeah. Oh. Yeah. I got through it by telling myself that time passes. Yeah. Time can't stop. This day will end. The sun will move through the sky. Night will come. the boat will dock and I will get off. That was the mantra I played in my head. It was my own personal, the edge. I was just going to say, you're like singing Annie. This sun will come out tomorrow. Basically. Oh my gosh. All right. That's the worst place I've ever been stuck. What about you? Well, Jenna, I actually was texting you from the worst place I've ever been stuck.
哦，不。九英寸。我是说。而且，你们知道的，在船上待了一整天。太可怕了。是的。哦。是的。我通过告诉自己时间在流逝来挺过这一关。是的。时间不会停止。这一天会结束。太阳会划过天空。夜晚会降临。船会靠岸，我会下船。这就是我在脑海中不断对自己说的心灵咒语。那是我个人的“边缘”。我本来想说，你简直就像在唱《安妮》。太阳明天就会升起。基本上就是这样。哦天哪。好了。那是去过最糟糕、被困住的地方。你呢？嗯，詹娜，我其实就是在去过最糟糕、被困住的地方时给你发短信的。
So I'm going to jog your memory now. Was it? Well, it was the, biggest snowstorm in North Texas in 21 years. It was December 24th, Christmas Eve, 2009. It's actually called the Christmas Eve blizzard. And I was flying back to see my family for the holidays with Isabel the morning of Christmas Eve. I think, Jenna, that year we worked right up into the holidays. So that was the day I could get out of town. And my dad said, well, there's a big storm coming in. So get the early flight. Get the earliest flight. Because once you land in Dallas, our family farm, is a good two and a half hour drive from Dallas. So we're talking rural farm-to-market roads.
所以我现在要唤醒你的记忆。是吗？嗯，那是北得克萨斯州21年来最大的暴风雪。那是2009年12月24日，平安夜。它其实被称为平安夜暴雪。平安夜那天早上，我和伊莎贝尔正坐飞机回家过节。我想，詹娜，那年我们一直工作到节假日前夕。所以那是唯一能离开镇子的日子。我爸爸说：嗯，有一场大风暴要来了。所以买早班机吧。买最早的航班。因为一旦你在达拉斯降落，我们家的农场距离达拉斯得有两个半小时的车程。所以我们说的是乡村通乡公路。
And, you know, they don't go out and treat those roads. They don't put salt on them. They ice over. So my dad was like, we are going to need to get on the road. Mm-hmm. Okay. So we land. Temperatures drop to, like, their 20s.
而且，你知道的，他们不会去清理那些道路。他们不在上面撒盐。路面会结冰。所以我爸爸说：我们必须马上上路。嗯哼。好吧。于是我们降落了。气温骤降到零下二十多度。
Winds kick up to like 60 miles an hour. It's snowing like crazy when we land. They close DFW Airport. Oh, I remember all this now. Yeah. No more flights going out. So we get in the car, and as we start to drive, it is just coming down and coming down. Isabel was only 19 months old.
风速飙升到每小时60英里左右。我们降落时雪下得疯狂。他们关闭了达拉斯/沃思堡国际机场。哦，我现在全想起来了。是的。没有航班起飞了。所以我们上了车，当我们开始开车时，雪就一直下个不停。伊莎贝尔当时只有19个月大。
It was me, my mom, my dad, Isabel, and Warren. And it was like a whiteout. My dad could barely see. We were watching cars slide off the road into snow drifts. I remember this. Hundreds of people were stranded in this storm. And, you know, these little towns did not have the resources to get this many people stranded out of the snow. So they called out.
车里有我、我妈妈、我爸爸、伊莎贝尔和沃伦。外面简直是一片白茫茫。我爸爸几乎什么也看不见。我们眼看着一辆辆车滑出路面，冲进雪堆。我记得这个。数百人被困在这场风暴中。而且，你知道的，这些小镇根本没有资源把这么多被困在大雪中的人救出来。所以他们呼叫了
like local farmers. They were getting their tractors, their plows, trying to get people out. I ran out of everything in our diaper bag. We ran out of food. We were stuck. And we made it as far as outside of this town called Decatur. And we were at the bottom of this hill. And when you got to the other side, the farmers had been kind of successful clearing the road a little bit on the other side, but no one could get over the hill. And it was just like all of these cars slid off in the snow. And then you'd watch another one try. And my dad sat there. We were running out of gas. And he would turn the car off to save the gas. And we'd get really cold. We would be able to see our breath. And then he'd turn the car on for a little bit. We'd warm up. And we were doing this like intermittently and just sitting there
当地的农民。他们开着拖拉机、除雪车，试图把人们救出来。我们尿布包里的所有东西都用光了。我们的食物吃完了。我们被困住了。我们一直开到迪凯特这个镇子外面。我们在这个山坡的底部。当你到了另一边，农民们在另一边清理道路方面取得了一些成功，但没有人能翻过这座山。就像所有这些车都滑进了雪里。然后你会看着另一辆车尝试。我爸爸坐在那里。我们的油快用完了。他会把车熄火来省油。我们会变得很冷。我们能看到哈出的白气。然后他会把车发动一会儿。我们暖和起来。我们断断续续地这样做，就坐在那里
watching car after car try this hill and go into the snowbank. Now it's nightfall. our windshield has frozen over and I'm getting really worried because I have a 19 month old and I'm just like, it's cold. We're running out of gas. And my dad was like, we got to go for it. We got to go for the hill. We just have to. And we had no, my dad, oh my gosh, my dad felt so bad because we never get this kind of weather there. He didn't have an ice scraper for the windshield. So he got out his country music CDs and busted him apart. so they'd get sharp and jagged, and they got out there, him and Warren, like, scraping off the ice on the windshield. My dad slipped and fell. I was like, oh, my gosh, Dad, are you okay? And I'll never
看着一辆又一辆车尝试这座山坡，然后冲进雪堆里。现在天黑了。我们的挡风玻璃结了冰，我开始非常担心，因为我有一个19个月大的孩子，我脑子里只有：太冷了。我们的油快用完了。我爸爸说：我们得拼一把。我们得冲上这个山坡。我们只能这样了。我们别无选择，我爸爸，哦天哪，我爸爸感到太糟糕了，因为我们在那里从来没有遇到过这种天气。他没有清理挡风玻璃的冰铲。所以他拿出了他的乡村音乐CD，把它们掰碎。这样它们就会变得锋利有锯齿，他和沃伦一起出去，像这样刮掉挡风玻璃上的冰。我爸爸滑倒了。我说：哦，天哪，爸爸，你没事吧？我永远不会
forget. My dad goes, I'm all right, but my dignity took a hit because he wiped out. Okay, I have to tell you, that's when I start texting you. I was like, Jenna, I'm worried. I'm worried. It is dark. People are stranded in their cars, and you said, Ange, I'm scared. I mean, as you're retelling this story. I am having all those feelings come back. And also, this is like, this is not a funny story. This is like a traumatic story. No, it's not. I'm sorry. But it's the It's the worst place I've ever been stuck. And so then while we're scraping the ice off the windshield, there's a young woman holding this little dog and she's out in the snow. Her cars run out of gas. And she's going from car to car that stranded knocking on the windows to see if someone will take
忘记。我爸爸说：我没事，但我的尊严受了打击，因为他摔了个大马趴。好吧，我得告诉你，那就是我开始给你发短信的时候。我说：詹娜，我很担心。我很担心。天黑了。人们被困在车里，你说：安吉，我很害怕。我的意思是，当你在重新讲述这个故事时。我所有的那些感觉又回来了。而且，这就像是，这不是一个有趣的故事。这就像是一个创伤性的故事。不，不是的。我很抱歉。但这是我去过最糟糕、被困住的地方。所以当我们刮掉挡风玻璃上的冰时，有一个年轻女子抱着一只小狗，她在大雪中。她的车没油了。她挨个敲击被困车辆的车窗，看有没有人能收留
her in. And she's, I don't know, she's probably in her 20s, you know. My dad waves at her. He's like, we'll make room because we had a big SUV. So now this young gal gets in the car with us with her Chihuahua. And I remember the Chihuahua's name was Jaze. So now we're all in it. And there's a 18-wheeler that's in front of us that's going to try the hill. He starts to go up. He slides sideways. off. And now it's our turn. You have to remind me, why have you not stopped for shelter? It's because there's just a vast nothingness between where you left and where you're going. Once you pass to Cater, for those of you guys that drive north in Texas, there's nothing for a while, you know? And my... No, that's what it's like when you drive to Kirksville, Missouri, which is where I went to school. There's just
她。她大概，我不知道，大概二十多岁吧。我爸爸向她挥手。他说：我们能腾出地方，因为我们有一辆大型SUV。于是这个年轻姑娘带着她的吉娃娃上了我们的车。我记得那只吉娃娃的名字叫杰斯。现在我们全在车上了。我们前面有一辆18轮大货车，它准备尝试翻过这个山坡。它开始往上开。它侧滑了。出去了。现在轮到我们了。你得提醒我，你们为什么不停车找个地方避难？因为从你出发的地方到你要去的地方之间是一片广袤的虚无。一旦过了迪凯特，对于你们这些在得克萨斯州往北开车的人来说，有一段时间什么都没有，你知道吗？我的……不，这就跟你开车去密苏里州基克斯维尔一样，那是我上学的地方。那里只有
like long stretches of there's no gas station. There's nothing. There's nothing. Just pasture. Just acres of just land with nothing on it, but some cows. So the 18-wheeler slides off, and I'm like, oh, my God, and now it's our turn. And I'm like, if we slide off, we're in a snowbank. Right now, we're on a road. So my mom just starts praying. Even if we get to the other side of the hill, we didn't have a plan, except in the neighboring little town, my parents knew a pastor that lived there. And he said, if we could make it to the town, we could stay at their house for the night. him and his wife and their two kids. So we start, my dad, I mean, my dad was such a hero in this moment. He starts the SUV with everything he has. He's just like going to gun it. He guns it and we're going
长长的一段路，没有加油站。什么都没有。什么都没有。只有牧场。只有大片大片什么也没有的土地，只有几头牛。所以18轮大货车滑出去了，我想：哦，天哪，现在轮到我们了。我想：如果我们滑出去了，我们就掉进雪堆里了。现在，我们还在路上。所以我妈妈开始祈祷。即使我们到了山的那一边，我们也没有计划，除了在邻近的小镇上，我父母认识那里的一位牧师。他说，如果我们能进到镇上，我们可以在他们家过夜。他和他的妻子还有他们的两个孩子。于是我们开始，我爸爸，我是说，我爸爸在这时简直是个英雄。他用尽全力发动了SUV。他就像是要猛踩油门。他猛踩油门，我们开始往上爬，
up and we are sliding left and right and sliding. And he's not turning into the slide. He's letting the car like just go with the slide. And there were a few times I was like, we're going to go off, we're going to go off. And we didn't. We didn't. And we made it to the top. I mean, you could have heard like it's like it was like the winning touchdown at the Super Bowl in that car we were like and isabel poor isabel i just don't even know what she remembers about this um i asked her if she remembered and she said she remembered snow and we get to the top of the hill and then we just slide we just coast down little by little we make it to this town we can't even get down the road that the pastor and his family live on but we get out and we weighed through the snow and
我们在左右滑行，一直在滑。他没有往滑动的反方向打方向盘。他让汽车顺着滑动的方向走。有几次我想：我们要冲出去了，我们要冲出去了。但我们没有。我们没有。我们成功登顶了。我是说，你简直可以听到，就像是超级碗上赢得达阵的那种欢呼声，在车里我们喊着：太棒了！可怜的伊莎贝尔，我甚至不知道她对这件事还记得什么，嗯，我问她是否还记得，她说她只记得雪。我们到了山顶，然后我们开始下滑，一点一点地滑下来，我们到了这个镇子，我们甚至无法开进牧师和他的家人住的那条街，但我们下车了，我们在雪地里跋涉，
And Giselle? And Giselle. Did she stay at the pastor's house, too? Yes. And I want to give a shout out to this pastor and his family. His name is Mike Sanders, and he and his wife, Andrea, were so lovely to me and my family, and I'm forever grateful. And on Christmas Eve night, at 11 p.m.
还有吉赛尔？还有吉赛尔。她也住在牧师家里吗？是的。我想向这位牧师和他的家人表达谢意。他的名字叫迈克·桑德斯，他和他的妻子安德烈亚对我和我的家人太好了，我永远心存感激。在平安夜的晚上，晚上11点
Okay, we started our drive at 3 p.m. At 11 p.m., we arrive at this pastor's house. We're waiting through the snow. I remember holding Isabel high up so she wouldn't get just damp from all the snow. because it was waist-high, and they took us in, we were starving. They fed five adults, a chihuahua, and a 19-month-old, and we woke up Christmas morning with this family. And finally, that young woman who got in the car with us was able to reach her dad,
好吧，我们下午3点开始开车。晚上11点，我们到达了这位牧师的家。我们在雪地里跋涉。我记得把伊莎贝尔高高抱起，这样她就不会被所有的雪弄潮湿了。因为雪深及腰，他们收留了我们，我们快饿死了。他们喂饱了五个成年人、一只吉娃娃和一个19个月大的孩子，我们在圣诞节早晨在这个家庭醒来。最后，那个上车的年轻女子联系到了她爸爸，
because, you know, she'd run out of cell service and everything. Her family, she was driving home for the holidays. They didn't know where she was. They knew she was stuck in this storm. Her dad and her brothers, because the roads still weren't. cleared, slowly made it to the pastor's house on Christmas Day. And when he arrived and he saw his daughter, he hugged her and began to cry. And then he turned to my dad, choked up and shook my dad's hand and said, thank you, thank you. Not a dry eye. We all were sobbing. And then she
因为，你知道的，她的手机没信号了什么的。她的家人，她是开车回家过节的。他们不知道她在哪里。他们知道她被困在这场风暴中。由于道路仍然没有被清理干净，她的父亲和兄弟们在圣诞节当天慢慢地赶到了牧师家。当他到达并看到他的女儿时，他拥抱了她并哭了起来。然后他转向我爸爸，哽咽着和我爸爸握手，说：谢谢，谢谢。没有一个人眼睛是干的。我们全都在痛哭流涕。然后她
was able to leave and go to her family's home. We didn't make it to our farm until Christmas day, late in the day, because we had to go so slow. But the roads were better. It was melancholy. melting. That's the longest I've ever been stuck anywhere. I mean, this also sounds like an answer to the question, what's your most memorable Christmas? I mean, that's right up there. Wow. Wow. Well, I think that if I had to choose, I would get back on the shark boat rather than do your adventure. Oh, gosh. Because, and I've never chosen the shark boat. Over something else. or something else. I've never, the shark boat has never won anything.
得以离开并前往她家人的家。直到圣诞节那天傍晚，我们才到达农场，因为我们必须开得很慢。但路况好多了。那是一种忧郁的融化。这是我去过被困时间最长的地方。我是说，这也听起来像是对“你最难忘的圣诞节是哪一个”这个问题的回答。我是说，这绝对名列前茅。哇。哇。好吧，我想如果我必须选择，我宁愿重新回到鲨鱼船上，也不愿去做你的冒险。哦，天哪。因为，而且我从来没有选过鲨鱼船。而不是别的。或者别的东西。我从来没有，鲨鱼船从来没有赢过任何东西。
Well, I mean, yeah. Because, you know why? Because you weren't just stuck, you were terrified. We were, I wasn't scared on the shark boat. I was just miserable. Yeah. Wow. Well, Stephanie, thank you for your question.
好吧，我是说，是的。因为，你知道为什么吗？因为你不仅被困住了，而且你吓坏了。我们是，我在鲨鱼船上一点都不害怕。我只是觉得痛苦而已。是的。哇。好吧，斯蒂芬妮，谢谢你的提问。
I mean, that was a real, like, zingdinger. I don't know the expression. But that was my honest answer. I was like, I mean, that's it. That's the worst place I've ever been. been stuck. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to break down the paper, season one, episode two. Where no one is stuck anywhere. True. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not
我是说，那真的是一个非常，怎么说呢。我不知道那个表达是什么。但那是我的真心话。我当时就想：我是说，就是这样。那是我去过被困住的最糟糕的地方。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们将剖析《The Paper》第一季第二集。没有人被困在任何地方的那一集。确实。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，仅仅因为这是新的一年，并不
mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally knew you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down. What might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Because those really just add up. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, What are big things? BetterHelp therapists can help.
意味着你必须成为一个全新的自己。但也许你想成为一个负担更少、思路更清晰的自己。不是一个完全崭新的你，但也许就像你想专注于核心。你想精进自我。是的。我喜欢这个。精进自我。嗯，心理咨询可以帮助你更轻松地识别是什么让你感到沉重。是什么可能在阻碍你。你可以更好地理解自己的人际关系、你的动力、你的情绪。我正在努力试着不去为小事感到压力。因为那些事情真的会积少成多。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。BetterHelp的心理咨询师可以提供帮助。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. All right. We are back, and we will be talking about the paper, season one, episode two, titled The Five Ws. This episode was written by Greg Daniels and Michael Komen and directed by Ken Kwapis.
拥有超过3万名心理咨询师，BetterHelp是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球超过500万人服务。BetterHelp让你轻松在网上匹配到合格的咨询师。注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 获取10%的优惠。网址是 better，H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。好了。我们回来了，我们将讨论《The Paper》第一季第二集，标题为《五个W》。这一集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克尔·科门编剧，肯·夸皮斯导演。
Aw, our favorite. Let me give you a summary. It's been a long time. Were you excited to give a summary? I was excited to give a summary, but I'm only doing one fast fact. And that's okay. Moving forward, these breakdowns will contain a single fast fact, not three. Here's a thing. We are not on the paper, but we know so many people who are working on the paper, so they're giving us little behind the scenes details, and I think it's okay that you're only doing one fast fact.
啊，我们最喜欢的。让我给你做个总结。好久不见了。你很兴奋能做总结吗？我很兴奋能做总结，但我只说一个快速事实。没关系。展望未来，这些剖析将包含一个快速事实，而不是三个。事情是这样的。我们没有出演《The Paper》，但我们认识很多在《The Paper》工作的人，所以他们给我们提供了一些幕后小细节，我觉得你只说一个快速事实是可以的。
Thank you, lady. Thank you. Well, here is your summary. Ned is struggling to stitch together his first issue of the floundering Toledo Truth Teller newspaper. As Moralda sabotages Ned's efforts by killing their wire service and doctoring his first letter to the readers. She still has it out for him. Well, yeah, she's bitter. Yeah. He's kind of replaced her. Yes, for sure. Yeah. He also stole her office. That wasn't necessary anything. I agree. Yeah. The staff of the paper become reporters, but no one really writes anything. And he has to turn this flop into a feature by writing a blunt and very earnest letter, owning that it was a quiet newsday, and rebooting the paper's promise to tell the truth. There you go. All right, fast fact number one, we are watching the
谢谢你，女士。谢谢。好吧，以下是你的总结。内德正在艰难地拼凑他作为苦苦挣扎的《托莱多实话实说报》的第一期报纸。埃斯梅拉达通过切断他们的电讯服务并篡改他写给读者的第一封信，蓄意破坏内德的努力。她依然在跟他过不去。嗯，是的，她心有不甘。是的。他有点取代了她。是的，肯定的。是的。他还偷了她的办公室。那倒不是完全必要的。我同意。是的。报社的工作人员成了记者，但实际上没人写任何东西。他不得不通过写一封直率而极其真诚的信，承认这是一个没有发生什么大新闻的日子，并重申报纸说实话的承诺，来把这个失败之作变成一个专题。就是这样。好的，快速事实一，我们正在观看这些《The Paper》剧集的
broadcast version of these episodes of the paper. You know they live on Peacock, but now they're also living on NBC Monday nights at 8.30. And I thought to myself, wait a second. They were really long on Peacock. But to be on broadcast, they can only be 22 minutes. Yeah. I asked Dave Rogers about it. He said, yeah, we had to cut them down. He said most of the episodes were like in the 28 to 29 minute range, and he had to spend his entire summer cutting them all down to 21 minutes and 30 seconds. It was like reverse supersizing that he's doing, he's, you know, for the office, he's doing the supersized episodes for Peacock. He had to do like reverse supersize. My gosh. What would you call that? Reverse supersized. I guess so. Yes. He said that because
广播版本。你知道它们在Peacock上播放，但现在它们也在每周一晚8点30分登陆NBC。我当时想：等一下。它们在Peacock上真的很长。但要在电视上播出，它们只能有22分钟。是的。我问了戴夫·罗杰斯这件事。他说：是的，我们不得不删减它们。他说大多数剧集的时长都在28到29分钟左右，他不得不花掉整个夏天把它们全部剪短到21分30秒。这就像是他在做“反向超大化”，你知道的，对于《办公室》，他为Peacock制作的是超大版剧集。他不得不做一个类似反向超大化的操作。我的天哪。你会怎么称呼那个？反向超大化。我想是的。是的。他说因为
so much time had to come out of each episode, both Greg and Michael really wanted to be involved in the process and they each had their own way of trimming the episode. He said Greg would take the broadcast scripts. So like after a show is broadcast, they turn it into a script because then it will incorporate all of the improvs and the way it was edited. That's right. It's like the transcripts you find online. Exactly. They form those after the episode airs. So Greg would take the broadcast scripts, and he would do what they call box cuts. That's where he would just put a giant box around certain scenes. And then if there were other little bits that related to that scene, they would cut those out too. But I guess Michael Komen would take the peacock cuts and actually
必须从每集里剪掉那么多时间，格雷格和迈克尔都非常想参与这个过程，他们俩都有各自修剪剧集的方式。他说格雷格会使用广播剧本。所以就像节目播出后，他们会把它变成剧本，因为那样会融合所有的即兴发挥和剪辑方式。没错。就像你在网上找到的剧本一样。 exatamente。它们是在剧集播出后形成的。所以格雷格会拿广播剧本，做他们所谓的“方框裁剪”。也就是他在某些场景周围画一个巨大的方框。如果还有其他与该场景相关的小片段，他们也会把那些剪掉。但我想迈克尔·科门会使用Peacock剪辑版，实际上
use editing software, where he pulled out little pieces of scenes and little pieces of dialogue to try to get down to the 21 minutes, 30 seconds. This is very interesting. This is very interesting. because it also is a little bit of a generational choice. Greg is clearly paper and pen, and Michael is computer. Dave said he would kind of use both of those as quote-unquote notes to determine how he would cut the episode down. But he said there were a couple times early on that Michael would suggest doing a different take of a scene because it was shorter or faster. And he and Greg had to explain that since this is a documentary, there aren't multiple takes. Right.
使用剪辑软件，从中抽出小块场景和小段对话，努力缩减到21分30秒。这非常有趣。这非常有趣。因为这也是一种代际选择。格雷格显然是纸笔派，而迈克尔是电脑派。戴夫说他会把这两种都作为所谓的“笔记”来决定他将如何剪辑这一集。但他说早期有几次迈克尔会建议采用同一场景的不同镜头，因为那个镜头更短或更快。他和格雷格不得不解释说，既然这是一部纪录片，就不存在多个镜头。没错。
So if a take or an angle lives in the original episode, it can't be changed. It can be removed, but it can't be a new version of that same scene. Exactly. So there you have it. That's your single fast fact. I like it. Well, let's get into the episode. this episode opens with Ned welcoming everyone into the conference room.
所以如果某个镜头或角度出现在原版剧集中，它是不能被改变的。它可以被移除，但不能是同一场景的新版本。Exactly。所以，这就是你的单一快速事实。我喜欢。好了，让我们进入正题。这一集以内德欢迎大家来到会议室开始。
Mm-hmm. Ned, you remember, is the brand-new editor-in-chief of the Truth Teller Paper, a newspaper that up until now has written no original stories. Yeah, they would just pull clips off of other news sites. But now they have to do it all on their own. Did you notice what the sign said on the door? I did. There's a handmade sign on the door.
嗯哼。内德，你们还记得，是《实话实说报》的全新总编辑，这家报纸直到现在也没有写过任何原创报道。是的，他们只会从其他新闻网站上摘录剪报。但现在他们必须全部靠自己了。你注意到门上的标志写的是什么了吗？我注意到了。门上有一个手写的标志。
As you walk into the conference room, it says Truth-Teller staff meeting 9 a.m. 9 a.m. I was like, that's kind of early. I mean, he has to get going. He does. Everyone is in the conference room except for two people. Oscar is not there. Yep. And Esmeralda is not there. And Ned starts by asking, how many people have written for a newspaper before? Only mayor. Only mayor. And everyone else's experience is pretty thin. Someone's like, oh, I have a text thread, really? That's their writing experience. I've tweeted. It's like the experience is real slim. Ned is now going to share his favorite issues of the Toledo Truth Teller.
当你走进会议室时，上面写着：实话实说报员工会议，上午9点。上午9点。我当时想：这未免也太早了。我是说，他必须得抓紧时间了。他确实得这样。每个人都在会议室里，除了两个人。奥斯卡不在。是的。埃斯梅拉达也不在。内德以提问开始：有多少人为报纸写过文章？只有市长。只有市长。其他所有人的经验都相当薄弱。有人说：哦，我有聊天群，真的吗？那是他们的写作经验。我发过推特。就像经验真的很匮乏。内德现在要分享他最喜欢的几期《托莱多实话实说报》。
He's taken like these newspapers, these front pages, they've been framed. They're like antiques that hang in the hallway of the building. And he brings his favorites into the room. These are the headlines on his favorite issues. Shepard orbits the Earth, Dr. Salk Cures Polio, and Victory in Europe. I looked up the headlines. I figured you would. So Alan Shepard did do a sub-orbit of the Earth in 1961.
他把这些报纸，这些头版，都装裱了起来。它们就像古董一样挂在大楼的走廊里。他把最喜欢的几期带到了房间里。这些是他最喜欢的头版头条新闻。谢泼德环绕地球飞行，索尔克医生治愈小儿麻痹症，以及欧洲胜利日。我查了一下这些头条新闻。我猜你肯定会查。所以艾伦·谢泼德确实在1961年进行了地球亚轨道飞行。
Dr. Salk created the polio vaccine in 1955, and victory in Europe was declared in 1945. I was like, how old is this paper? These headlines go back to 1945. I mean, you remember what the printing press looked like. It was in black and white. Oh, yeah, that's right. Well, then I looked up my hometown paper of the St. Louis Post to Span. Yeah.
索尔克医生于1955年研制出了脊髓灰质炎疫苗，欧洲胜利日在1945年宣布。我当时想：这报纸到底有多老？这些头条新闻可以追溯到1945年。我是说，你还记得印刷机长什么样吗？那是黑白的。哦，对，没错。然后我查了我的家乡报纸《圣路易斯邮报》。是的。
The first issue of the St. Louis Post Dispatch was December 12th, 1878. You go, St. Louis. 1878. I saw a picture of the front page. It was almost all ads. Hmm. Were early newspapers just, it looked kind of like just an ad section and the, oh, the ads lady, you would have loved it.
《圣路易斯邮报》的第一期是1878年12月12日。加油，圣路易斯。1878年。我看到了一张头版照片。几乎全都是广告。嗯。早期的报纸是不是，看起来有点像只有广告版块，哦，打广告的女士，你一定会喜欢的。
Oh, I bet. It was like needlepoint napkins now on sale. Mm-hmm. Lace gloves, half off. Lace gloves! Yes! Well, Ken, he's kind of like one of the boss guys over everything. He's this British guy.
哦，我敢打赌。就像现在正在大减价的针织餐巾。嗯哼。蕾丝手套，半价。蕾丝手套！是的！好吧，肯，他有点像是管着所有事情的老板之一。他是个英国人。
He's going to come in and stir up some shit. And I just want you guys to know, I have a few people in this episode that I'm calling shi-stirers. Oh, is he one of them? He's one of them. And I had to call a bullshit card on him right out of the gate. Yeah, I'm sorry. What is it? Well, Ken comes in the room and he's like, I'm sorry, you can't use these.
他要来搞点事情。我只想让你们知道，我在这一集里有几个我称之为“搅局者”的人。哦，他是其中之一吗？他是其中之一。我一上来就不得不给他亮出了一张扯淡牌。是的，我很抱歉。怎么回事？嗯，肯走进房间说：很抱歉，你们不能在会议室开会时使用这些
framed newspapers in your conference room meeting. I'm going to take them all back. Why? Why? Why can't he show these framed, like newspapers to his staff? Oh, I'm sorry, he's got to go hang him back on the hallway. Okay, great. Then everyone can just walk to the hallway. Right? Really? I guess he was worried about them getting damaged, but did you see the person who drops them on the floor? It's Ken. I know. at two minutes. As he's leaving the conference room, he drops him on the floor. Yeah. And guess what? I have a tidbit about that. Okay. So when we shared that we were going to be breaking down these episodes, the amazing Chelsea Frye, who plays mayor, she reached out to us, and she said she was so excited. And she said, ask me any questions. So I asked her if she had any memories from this episode, and she said this conference room meeting. She said it was essentially the first conference room meeting. where everybody was all together, and they were so nervous. They felt like there was a lot to live up to. So she said that when Tim Key, who placed Ken, left with all the framed articles,
装裱好的报纸。我要把它们全拿回去。为什么？为什么？他为什么不能把这些装裱好的报纸拿给他的员工看？哦，对不起，他得把它们挂回走廊去。哦，太棒了。那大家直接去走廊看不就行了。对吧？真的吗？我猜他担心它们会损坏，但你看到那个把它们掉在地上的人了吗？是肯。我知道。在两分钟时。当他离开会议室时，他把它们掉在了地上。是的。你猜怎么着？我有一个关于那个的小花絮。好吧。所以当我们分享我们要剖析这些剧集时，饰演市长的了不起的切尔西·弗莱联系了我们，她说她非常兴奋。她说：随便问我什么问题。所以我问她对这一集有什么回忆，她提到了这个会议室会议。她说这基本上是第一次所有人都聚在一起的会议室会议。
he dropped them, and it was an accident. No, it's so perfect. It's so perfect. And she said it broke the tension. Everybody couldn't stop laughing. And then they left it in. I think that's great. Oh, Chelsea, great tidbit.
每个人都紧张极了。他们觉得自己有很多期望要达到。所以她提到当饰演肯的蒂姆·基拿着所有装裱好的文章离开时，
I do have a favorite moment in this conference room scene. And it's when Barry lights a cigarette and he smokes a cigarette. I know. That's longer in the peacock version. Yeah. He's like smoking a cigarette through the whole meeting. No one says anything. No one's like, do you mind like the smoke?
他不小心把它们掉在地上了，那是意外。不，太完美了。太完美了。她说这打破了紧张气氛。大家笑得停不下来。然后他们把这个留在了正片里。我觉得这太棒了。哦，切尔西，好棒的小花絮。
Nothing. Yes. And by the way, after Ken leaves, this conference room meeting just sort of ends. Yeah, it just sort of ends and everyone kind of goes back to their desk, I guess. Yes. Ned is going to go up to Mayor at her desk, and they're excited. They're going to start this first issue. They're going to go to the AP wire and start pulling articles. Yes. And then Ned spies a tin of popcorn under Mayor's desk and is like, hey, can I have some of that? And she's like, yeah, sure. And here's the thing. There would have been a Mayor talking head right after this. Like as soon as Ned starts diving in that popcorn tin, Mayor would have said something I thought was hilarious. It's still in the peacock. version. It's not in the NBC broadcast, but I want you to hear about this popcorn. It brought back
我确实在这一场会议室戏中有一个最喜欢的时刻。那就是巴里点燃了一支烟并抽起烟来。我知道。在Peacock版里这个镜头更长。是的。他整个会议都在抽烟。没有人说什么。没有人说：你介意这烟味吗？
some memories for me. Hey, can I have some of this? Uh, yeah, sure. Yeah, dive in. Looks good. That popcorn was a gift to Maria, who had my desk before me from Enrique, who used to work in sales. They have two kids now. Yes. This popcorn, it's one of those giant tins that's, like, divided in three. Yeah. And Ned's going to eat it. through this entire episode. You see him carry this tin around. He's like basically like... Stress eating. Yes. Yes. He's stressed eating maybe four-year-old popcorn. I mean, they have two kids? Two kids. Six-year-old popcorn? I mean, they had to fall in love, get married, and have two children, and not work there anymore. It reminded me when Ed ate those Twizzlers that had been on the set for like four years. What is that story?
什么都没有。是的。顺便说一句，肯离开后，这个会议室的会议就这么结束了。是的，就这么结束了，大家各自回到了自己的座位上，我想是的。内德走到市长的办公桌前，他们很兴奋。他们要开始制作第一期了。他们要去看AP电传并开始挑选文章。是的。然后内德在市长的办公桌底下发现了一罐爆米花，就问：嘿，我能吃点那个吗？她回答：行啊，当然。事情是这样的。这后面本来应该有一个市长的单人访谈。就在内德把手伸进爆米花罐的那一刻，市长会说一些我觉得非常搞笑的话。这个片段在Peacock
Don't you remember we had all those Were they Twizzlers or Red Vines? I can't remember in the kitchen And they'd been there for years Oh, the big tub of Red Vines Yes On the set of the office in the kitchen And they were there for years
版里还在。NBC的电视广播版里没有，但我希望你听听关于这个爆米花的事。它勾起了一些我的回忆。嘿，我能吃点这个吗？呃，行啊，当然。吃吧，抓一把。看起来不错。那爆米花是以前坐在我这个位置的玛丽亚收到的礼物，送她礼物的是恩里克，他以前在销售部工作。他们现在有两个孩子了。是的。这爆米花，是那种分成了三格的巨大铁罐。是的。内德要把它吃个底朝天。
And then when Ed was new to the show One day I saw him open it up And take one out I'm like, bah But they've been here a while He'd already eaten like half of it I think that they last forever I think they might
贯穿整整一集。你看到他带着这个罐子到处走。他基本上就像是在……化解压力。是的。是的。他可能在压力性进食存放了四年的爆米花。我是说，他们有两个孩子？两个孩子。六年的爆米花？我是说，他们得相爱、结婚、生了两个孩子，而且不在那儿工作了。这让我想起当年爱德吃了那些在片场放了大概四年的红藤软糖。那是个什么故事？
I do have a question for you What is it? Are you red vines Twizzlers. Oh, this is tough. Yeah. I am red vines at the movies. Okay. But I am Twizzlers at Lake of the Ozarks. What? My whole childhood, my mom would buy a pack of Twizzlers, which she calls liqueish. Liquish. Yeah. Do you want some liqueish? This is adorable. She doesn't call it licorice. But she would buy... Also, it's not liqueish or licorish. Isn't it liquorish? It's red licorish. Is it? I think so.
你不记得我们有那么多……那是红藤软糖还是喴糖？我不记得在厨房里了。哦，那大桶的红藤软糖。是的。在《办公室》片场的厨房里。它们在那里放了好几年。
Oh. But she would buy a big pack when we would go down to the lake for a week and you could just go in the cabinet whenever you wanted and you could take one. Because there's no like the cool thing about Lake of the Ozarks and my childhood was that you could just eat chips. Different rules. Yes. Oreos and red licorice. This is like what I call. Willy-nilly.
然后当爱德刚加入剧组时。有一天我看到他打开它。拿了一根出来。我说：呃……但它们在那儿放了好久了。他其实已经吃了一半了。我想它们能保存永远吧。我想是的。
Plain travel. Like we get to the airport, the kids can get whatever snack they want for the plane. Right. You know? Yes. And can get skittles, whatever. It's the plane. What are you?
我确实有个问题想问你。什么问题？你是红藤派还是喴糖派。哦，这很难选。是的。看电影时我是红藤派。好吧。但在奥沙克湖时我是喴糖派。什么？我整个童年，我妈妈都会买一包喴糖，她叫它“licorice”（甘草糖），发音成liqueish。Liquish。是的。你想吃点liqueish吗？这太可爱了。她不叫它licorice。而且，那既不是liqueish也不是licorish。难道不应该是licorish吗？
I'm Red Vines. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, Ned is old popcorn tin. Super old popcorn tin. I asked Chelsea about the popcorn because as I was watching him eat this popcorn throughout the whole episode, I was like, did anybody besides Donal eat the popcorn? Because I just had a hunch.
哦。但当我们去湖边度假一周时，她会买一大包，只要你想，随时可以去橱柜拿一根。因为没有那种……奥沙克湖和我的童年最酷的地方在于，你可以随便吃薯片。规则不一样。是的。奥利奥和红甘草糖。这就是我所说的。随心所欲。
Yeah. Just like what you're talking about, Ed, eating food, and I know B.J. and I would eat prop food that wasn't ours. Yeah. She said, oh, my God, yes. she ate so much of it that she was sick by the end of the week. She said Taylor from props had to refill it constantly. Okay, well, I was very curious about this popcorn tin as well, and I reached out to the prop master for the paper, Scott McGinnis.
飞机上的零食。就像我们到了机场，孩子们可以在飞机上买他们想要的任何零食。对吧？是的。可以买彩虹糖什么的。这是飞机上。你属于哪一派？
We met him, remember, when we're on set. And I asked him these questions, Scott, did the actors all really eat the popcorn? It looked like a lot of popcorn. Where did you get it from? What were the flavors? And was there a spit bucket? What are the answers?
我是红藤派。嗯哼。嗯哼。是的。好吧，内德的旧爆米花罐。超级旧的爆米花罐。我问过切尔西关于爆米花的事，因为当我看着他整集都在吃这罐爆米花时，我在想：除了多纳尔，真的有人吃过这爆米花吗？因为我只是有个直觉。
Here's what Scott said. The popcorn and tin were from Shirley's, a popular Ohio brand. Oh, I love this. Yeah, and he sent me the link so I can share it. He said, the actors ate quite a bit, but mostly donal, who goes full into everything. Sounds like rain, doesn't it? Scott also said, the most popular flavor was, any guesses? Cheese?
就像你刚才说的爱德吃食物一样，我知道B.J.和我也会吃别人的道具食物。是的。她说：哦，天哪，是的。她吃得太多了，以至于到周末结束时她都生病了。她说道具组的泰勒不得不经常重新填满它。好吧，我对这个爆米花罐也充满好奇，我联系了《The Paper》的道具总监斯科特·麦金尼斯。
White cheddar. Oh! He said, it's good popcorn, and I don't remember needing a spit bucket. I like this inside info. Here's what's going to happen next in the episode. Mare and Ned discover that the wire service has been canceled. They can't get any stories. Yeah.
白切达干酪。哦！他说，这是很好的爆米花，而且我不记得需要吐渣桶了。我喜欢这个内幕消息。接下来这一集里会发生这些事。梅尔和内德发现通讯社被取消了。他们拿不到任何报道。是的。
As Marelda comes by, and in her very passive-aggressive way, she's like, oh, yes, I canceled the wire service because you so brilliantly declared that we would be writing original news stories. Yeah. This was your idea. Yeah, I did this for you. Mm-hmm. And he's like, what the fuck?
当玛丽尔达走过来时，她用那种非常被动攻击的方式说，哦，是的，我取消了通讯社，因为你们那么高明地宣称我们要写原创的新闻报道。是的。这是你的主意。是的，我是为了你才这么做的。嗯哼。然后他说，搞什么鬼？
And she's very sabotagey. And then she mentions this lunch that they have. Yes. She's like, I'll see you at lunch. And then Ned panics, and he calls everybody back into the conference room. Because now they have to go get news stories today, right now. The deadline for printing is 6 p.m. Yes. Here are the news stories that they're going to chase down. This is all they could come up with. Adelola couldn't find a parking space at the dog park. They're on it. They're going to get to the bottom of that. Who's taking up all these extra parking spaces?
而且她非常喜欢搞破坏。然后她提到了他们要一起吃的午饭。是的。她说，午餐见。然后内德慌了，他把大家都叫回了会议室。因为现在他们今天就得去搞到新闻报道，就在现在。印刷截止时间是下午6点。是的。这是他们要去追踪报道的新闻。这就是他们能想出来的内容。阿德洛拉在狗公园找不到停车位。他们正盯着呢。他们要查清这件事。到底是谁占了这么多额外的停车位？
Yes. There's a water main break in town. So Mayor and Barry are going to go find out what's going on with that. Did you catch as Barry gets up to leave? He throws his cigarette over his shoulder? No. I did not. I was like, did he just throw a lit cigarette over his shoulder?
是的。镇上有一处水管主管道破裂。所以市长和巴里要去看看那边到底怎么回事。你注意到巴里起身要走的时候了吗？他把烟头从肩膀后方扔了出去？没有。我没注意到。我当时想，他刚才是把一根点着的烟从肩膀后方扔出去了吗？
My gosh. Travis says that there are some fishing limits that have changed at the wildlife preserve. Mm-hmm. So he and Detrick are going to go find out. And finally, Ned says, Nicole, will you please look at the crime beat? Like, look at all the, like, apps and call all the places and find out, you know, any crimes. Yes. And then Ned says, I'm going to write a letter from the editor.
天哪。特拉维斯说野生动物保护区的某些捕鱼限制改变了。嗯哼。所以他和迪特里克要去查清楚。最后，内德说，妮可，你能看一下犯罪新闻版块吗？比如，看一下所有的那些，比如应用程序，给所有地方打电话，然后查一下，你知道的，有没有什么犯罪案件。是的。然后内德说，我要写一封主编寄语。
And this is going to be our paper. It's going to be great. everyone go get to it. Mm-hmm. Lady, did you know that I was a journalism minor in college? Yes, I feel like in the back folder of my brain of our friendship, I remember this. Yes, I was a pre-law history major and a journalism minor. I changed my major to theater, but I did graduate with a minor in journalism, and I found
这将是我们的报纸。这会很棒的。大家都去干活吧。嗯哼。女士，你知道我大学时选修过新闻学吗？知道，我觉得在我们友谊的大脑后备文件夹里，我记得这件事。是的，我是法律预科历史专业，还辅修了新闻学。我把专业改成了戏剧，但我确实是以新闻学辅修学位毕业的，而且我找到了
three of the stories that I wrote for the index, which was my college paper during my, like, you know, time in the journalism department. Please tell me you're going to share one. I'm just going to share the subject of each of them because I thought they were pretty cool. Okay. Can I just say Jenna's holding up papers that have like kind of started to turn yellow? They're so old. They were typed on a typewriter.
我为《指数报》写的三篇报道，那是我在大学期间，也就是你知道的，在新闻系呆的那段时间里的校报。求求你告诉我你会分享一篇。我只打算分享其中每一篇的主题，因为我觉得它们挺酷的。好的。我能说珍娜正拿着一些已经开始发黄的纸吗？太旧了。它们是用打字机打出来的。
Oh, my goodness. And then I would turn these in. So, Jenna Fisher for the index is what it says. They might be giants and Matthew Sweet teamed up last Friday night in Pershing Arena for a very successful St. Patrick's Day concert. As of last Thursday, SAB had sold a little over 1,000 tickets.
噢，天哪。然后我会把这些交上去。所以，珍娜·费舍尔为《指数报》撰稿，上面就是这么写的。“巨人”乐队和马修·斯威特上周五晚上在珀辛竞技场联手举办了一场非常成功的圣帕特里克节音乐会。截至上周四，学生活动委员会（SAB）已经售出了略多于1000张门票。
Mm-hmm, and then I have quotes because you had to get quotes. Lady, you basically had fast facts. Oh my gosh, is this where it started? I think so. Okay, here's my next one. Jenna Fisher for the index. Springtime is bringing more than flowers
嗯哼，然后我有了引语，因为你得弄到引语。女士，你基本上就是快讯。天哪，这就是一切的起点吗？我想是的。好吧，这是我的下一篇。珍娜·费舍尔为《指数报》撰稿。春天带来的可不只是花朵
to Kirksville this year. The Kirksville Planning and Zoning Commission met last Wednesday to discuss the possibility of adding a Walgreens drugstore on the corner of Illinois and Baltimore streets across from Hy-Vee. But before the store can be built, the property must be rezoned from residential to commercial causing controversy among some homeowners in the area. Ooh, scuttlebutt. Mm-hmm. This was my two-part series. This is going to get serious. Jenna Fisher for the index. This story is part one of a two-part series on how recent sexual attacks have shaken the
今年对柯克斯维尔来说。柯克斯维尔规划与分区委员会上周三开会讨论了在海威超市（Hy-Vee）对面、伊利诺伊街和巴尔的摩街转角处增设一家Walgreens药店的可能性。但在该店建成之前，这处房产必须从住宅用地重新区划为商业用地，这在该地区的一些房主中引发了争议。噢，八卦流言。嗯哼。这是我的两部分系列报道。这下要认真起来了。珍娜·费舍尔为《指数报》撰稿。这篇报道是关于最近的性袭击事件如何动摇了
normally quiet Midwestern college town of Crook'sville, Missouri. Part one deals with the ongoing efforts of law enforcement officials to regain control of their town. Part two will deal with the ways citizens have decided to fight back against the recent attacks by taking matters into their own hands. So this was kind of my crime beat. They assign you different sections of the paper. Sure. So this was when I was on crime beat. I had to interview people, but apparently I didn't do a very good job in part one because my teacher wrote, anything from the police department? This is supposed to be the law enforcement side. You have very little from them. I guess I didn't do a very good job on that story. I don't even know if it ran. It may not have run. Lady, I see so much
密苏里州克鲁克斯维尔这个平时安静的中西部大学镇的两部分系列报道的第一部分。第一部分探讨了执法官员为重新控制他们的城镇而正在做出的努力。第二部分将探讨市民们如何决定通过亲力亲为、自己动手来回击最近的袭击。所以这有点像是我的犯罪新闻版块。他们会给你分配报纸的不同版块。当然。所以这是我在负责犯罪新闻版块的时候。我必须采访人们，但显然我在第一部分里没做好，因为我的老师写道，警察局有什么消息吗？这应该是执法部门的角度。你从他们那了解到的内容非常少。我想我在那篇报道上没做好。我甚至不知道它有没有见报。可能根本没发。女士，我看到了好多的
of you, like early you in all three of those. Jenna Fisher from the index. Jenna Fisher from the index? Oh, my gosh. Oh, lady, I used to walk around with a little spiral pad. And I would say, hi, Jenna Fisher from the index. I'm here to do a story on whatever. Just like Adelola in the parking lot. She had her little notepad. She was very serious with it. Exactly. Well, you know, I mean, we had talked about this earlier when we were rewatching this episode. And I shared with Jenna, you guys, and I have to tell you all. And I've mentioned this on the podcast before that my grandmother, Lena McKinsey, had a column in the Archer City paper. Yes. I can't even believe this, you guys. I found one of her columns. Get this. There is a website called Portal to Texas History. They are archiving rare historical
你，那种早期的你，在那三篇里面全都有。珍娜·费舍尔来自《指数报》。珍娜·费舍尔来自《指数报》？噢，天哪。噢，女士，我过去常常拿着一个小螺旋记事本走来走去。然后我会说，嗨，我是来自《指数报》的珍娜·费舍尔。我来这里是为……做一篇报道。就像停车场里的阿德洛拉一样。她拿着她的小记事本。她对此非常严肃。没错。好吧，你知道的，我们之前在重温这一集的时候聊过这个。我和珍娜分享了这件事，你们大家，我得告诉你们所有人。而且我在之前的播客里也提到过，我的祖母莱娜·麦肯齐曾在《阿彻城报》上有一个专栏。是的。我简直不敢相信，你们大家。我找到了她的一篇专栏。听着这个。有一个叫做“德克萨斯历史门户”的网站。他们正在归档所有关于德克萨斯的稀有历史
and primary source materials all about Texas. It's been created and maintained by the University of North Texas libraries. Thank you so much to those folks because I found my grandmother's column. It was like I got to spend a little moment in time with her. It was so wonderful. Are you going to read it? Yes, I am. First of all, I stand corrected. I always say, thought her column was called Around the Town. I think that was an early name of it. Okay. But it was actually called Around Archer. And here it is, Around Archer by Mrs. Finus Kinsey. It is basically just, I think people let her know what they were doing, and then she would write up and say what they were doing. So here's an example. Mr. and Mrs. Ralph Wolf of Azel visited
和第一手资料。这是由北德克萨斯大学图书馆创建并维护的。非常感谢那些朋友，因为我找到了我祖母的专栏。就像是我有机会和她共度了一小段美好的时光。太棒了。你要读出来吗？是的，我要读。首先，我要收回前言。我一直以为，她的专栏叫《城里城外》。我想那是它早期的名字。好吧。但它其实叫《阿彻周遭》，作者是菲尼斯·金西夫人。它基本上就是，我觉得人们把他们在做的事情告诉她，然后她就会写下来并说他们在做什么。所以这是一个例子。来自阿塞尔的拉ルフ·沃尔夫先生和夫人上周五去拜访了
their son and his wife, Coach Terry Wolfe, and Deidre last Friday. That's it. That's it. Next one. Rattlesnakes are moving in. Ron Mullins killed one in town, 47 inches long. I would read this column every week. Yeah.
他们的儿子和儿媳、教练特里·沃尔夫以及迪德尔。就这样。就这样。下一个。响尾蛇搬进来了。罗恩·马林斯在镇上打死了一条，47英寸长。我每周都会读这个专栏。是的。
I love this. Here's one more. The Youth Fellowship Group of the First United Methodist Church traveled to Dallas, Texas Saturday for the Tulane v. Southern Methodist University football game at Irving Stadium. The group of 20 camped out at the youth hall of a Dallas Methodist Church where they attended services the following morning. Can I get on my soapbox for a second? Can I just say that this is what is missing from today? This, this tidbits of community.
我太喜欢这个了。还有一个。第一联合卫理公会的青年团契小组上周六前往德克萨斯州达拉斯，在欧文体育场观看杜兰大学对阵南方卫理公会大学的足球比赛。这群20人露营在达拉斯一家卫理公会教堂的青年活动大厅里，并在第二天早上在那里参加了礼拜。我能发表一下我的高论吗？我能说这就是当今社会所缺失的东西吗？这个，这些社区的琐事。
How amazing is this, how it stitches you together, just knowing little bitty things that they went to visit their son. I love that. I love that that guy killed the rattlesnake. That was my brother-in-law. This is, we need more of this in our lives today. these, when I click on quote-unquote, like news sites, it's not news. There's no news. It's just the same recycled bullshit over and over again. It's just the same like political divide. It doesn't build community. That builds community. That is beautiful. It's meaningful.
这多么神奇啊，它把你们缝合在了一起，仅仅通过了解那些他们去拜访儿子的微小事情。我喜欢这样。我喜欢那个家伙打死了响尾蛇。那是我小叔子。这是，我们的生活中需要更多这样的东西。这些，当我点击那些所谓的“新闻网站”时，根本不是新闻。没有新闻。只有一遍又一遍回收的同样的狗屎。只有同样的政治分歧。它无法建立社区。那才能建立社区。那太美妙了。那是有意义的。
We need more of that. I know. I loved it. And there's little tidbit after little tidbit. and I just want to share with you the editor's note at the end. Please. Editor's note, semicolon, remember to call Mrs. Kinsey, and then they gave her phone number, to report Archer City activities. We have had many, many requests from readers for more around Archer events. This is the first time in four years that we have had a local correspondent. Help us to make the news your news.
我们需要更多这样的东西。我知道。我太喜欢了。而且还有接连不断的琐事。我只想和你们分享最后的编者按。请吧。编者按，分号，记得给金西夫人打电话（随后给出了她的电话号码），以汇报阿彻城的活动。我们收到了读者提出的许许多多关于更多“阿彻周遭”活动的请求。这是我们四年来第一次拥有当地通讯员。帮助我们让新闻成为你们的新闻。
I love it. How can we start this? How can this happen? Isn't that wonderful? That was the first time in four. years and the local correspondent was my grandmother. Now, I know that there are like local church newsletters, school newsletters. I know that there are like community newsletters. I subscribe to my town newsletter. I do too. I get it quarterly
我太喜欢了。我们怎么才能开始这样做呢？这怎么才能实现呢？这不是太美妙了吗？那是四年来第一次，而当地通讯员就是我的祖母。现在，我知道有很多像当地教堂通讯、学校通讯。我知道有很多像社区通讯。我订阅了我镇上的通讯。我也是。我每季度收到一次
and I love it for this reason. Yes. But we need this, how do we make this like a national thing? Like wouldn't you just feel so much closer to everybody if you got little tidbits? Yeah, I think I would. I think it's nice. It's just, it makes people feel more similar than a part. Yes. Yeah. All right. I don't know how to make this happen. Well, maybe we can start making it happen here a little at a time. Should we start a folder called tidbits? Yes, and you could tell us just a little around your town tidbit, and we'll share it on the podcast. I love this. Yes. Oh, can we call it around the town? in honor of my grandmother?
而且我就因为这个原因很喜欢它。是的。但我们需要这个，我们怎么把它变成全国性的事情呢？难道你不觉得如果你能收到这些小琐事，你会感觉和所有人更亲近吗？是的，我想我会的。我觉得这很好。这只是，它让人们觉得彼此更加相似而不是疏远。是的。是的。好吧，我不知道怎么让它实现。嗯，也许我们可以从这里开始一点一点让它实现。我们要不要建一个叫“琐事”的文件夹？是的，你可以跟我们分享一点你镇上的小琐事，然后我们会在播客里分享它。我太喜欢了。是的。哦，我们可以叫它“城里城外”吗？为了致敬我的祖母？
Yes. Done. Everyone, please go to OfficeLadies.com. Look for our folder titled Around the Town and send us some news about your town. Yeah. Or what you did. Yes.
好的。搞定。各位，请访问 OfficeLadies.com。寻找我们标题为“城里城外”的文件夹，并给我们发送一些关于你们城镇的新闻。是的。或者你做了什么。是的。
For the weekend. Exactly. Did you kill a rattlesnake we want to know? Yeah. Did your home football team go to the playoffs? Yes. Well, I'm very excited and I feel inspired. Me too.
周末的时候。没错。你打死了一条响尾蛇吗？我们想知道。是的。你们当地的高中足球队进季后赛了吗？是的。好吧，我非常兴奋，而且我感觉备受鼓舞。我也是。
And my grandmother would be so proud, I think. She should be proud. Yeah. Well, let's get back to breaking down this episode. Nicole is going to knock on Ned's door and say, listen, as a single woman living alone, I cannot do the crime beat. No. I need my bubble of ignorance.
而且我祖母会为此感到骄傲的，我想。她应该感到骄傲。是的。好吧，让我们回到剖析这一集来。妮可要敲响内德的门并说，听着，作为一个独居的单身女性，我无法负责犯罪新闻版块。不。我需要我的无知保护罩。
Could we please switch assignments? How about I write the letter from the editor and you do the crime beat? You know, I did notice in the conference room when she looked on her phone and saw one of the first crimes, it was like a guy with a machete or something, she then took her phone and hit it under her purse. Oh. I thought that was a nice little, like, a little nugget there that she does not want anything to do with this. I mean, it makes sense to me. This is why I don't watch, like, haunted house scary movies because I can't have that in my head as I'm falling asleep in my 100-year-old house that I'm convinced is maybe a little haunted, you know? Too close to home. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Now we're going to go to the dog park because we're going to try to figure out why there's no. parking spaces. Remember, Adam and Adelola are asking questions of a park employee. And they're
我们能换一下工作吗？不如我来写主编寄语，你去做犯罪新闻版块？你知道的，我确实注意到在会议室里，当她看手机并看到第一起犯罪案件时，那是一个拿着大砍刀之类的人，她随后把手机塞进了钱包下面。哦。我觉得这是一个不错的细节，就像一个小彩蛋，表明她不想和这事扯上任何关系。我的意思是，这对我来说很合理。这就是为什么我不看那种鬼屋恐怖电影，因为当我试图在我那座我确信可能有点闹鬼的百年老宅里入睡时，脑子里不能装着那些画面，你知道的？太贴近现实了。是的。是的。好吧，现在我们要去狗公园，因为我们要试着弄清楚为什么没有停车位。记住，亚当和阿德洛拉正在向公园员工提问。而且他们
asking them, like, in a way, like there's something sketchy going on. Like, what's up with the lack of parking? Yeah. And the guy's like, well, if you look at the sign, the parking is for park employees to unload their things. This guy that plays this role is brilliant. Do you know who it is? I didn't know who it was. I did. It's Nick Thune. Yes. Yeah. I went down a whole rabbit hole. He's so good. He's so no nonsense, but he's also not a dick in the role, you know? He's really great. He's a comedian, and he's been on tour with Nate Bargotsie. Yeah. No, he's fantastic. He's done a gazillion things. I started watching all his YouTube specials. He plays guitar while he does his comedy. It's very charming. It's very soothing. Yeah. And very funny.
问他们的方式，好像有什么可疑的事情在发生。比如，停车位短缺是怎么回事？是的。然后那个人说，嗯，如果你看标牌，这个停车场是给公园员工卸货用的。扮演这个角色的家伙太棒了。你知道他是谁吗？我不知道他是谁。我知道。是尼克·图恩（Nick Thune）。是的。是的。我进行了一次深度搜索。他太棒了。他如此务实，但在剧中他也不是个混蛋，你知道吗？他真的很棒。他是个喜剧演员，曾和内特·巴加茨（Nate Bargatze）一起巡演。是的。不，他太棒了。他做过无数的事情。我开始看他所有的YouTube特辑。他一边弹吉他一边表演喜剧。非常迷人。非常舒缓。是的。而且非常搞笑。
I feel like he was a huge git. Like, I hope he comes back in this role somehow. That would be amazing. The other thing that's going on is that mayor calls Ned to let him know that Barry's injured. I guess somehow walking down a sidewalk, he put his foot through a wooden crate. He's sprawled out on the ground. He's in a lot of pain. Shout out Chelsea to this deep squat that you hold throughout the whole scene. I was very impressed. Ned is like, okay, can you go see what's happening with the water main break?
我觉得他是个超级大腕。希望他能以某种方式再次出演这个角色。那将是太棒了。另一件发生的事是市长打电话给内德，告诉他巴里受伤了。我想他不知怎么在走廊上走路时，把脚踩进了一个木箱里。他四脚朝天地趴在地上。他痛得很厉害。向切尔西大声喊话，感谢你在整场戏中一直保持着这个深蹲。我印象深刻。内德说，好吧，你能去看看水管主管道破裂那边是怎么回事吗？
And she's like, I told him I'd ride in the ambulance with him. It doesn't look like he needs an ambulance, but apparently one has been called. Yeah. And Ned's like, could the ambulance swing by the water main break on the way to the hospital? No. And then he's like, I don't think so. And then he's like, fine. Can you just get me any details about what's happening at the hospital?
然后她说，我告诉过他我要跟他一起坐救护车。看起来他不需要救护车，但显然已经叫了一辆。是的。然后内德说，救护车能在去医院的路上顺便绕去水管破裂的地方吗？不。然后他说，我想不能。接着他说，好吧。你能帮我打听一下医院那边发生的情况的任何细节吗？
He's getting so desperate. I want to point out something. Background catch. All right. While Ned is talking to her, behind him on a credenza, go to nine minutes and 41 seconds. Clacky balls. No. Yep.
他越来越绝望了。我想指出一件事。背景花絮。好吧。当内德在跟她说话时，在他身后的一个长餐具柜上，来到9分41秒。碰撞球。没有。是的。
No, there's not. Big old set of clacky balls. Mm-hmm. Wow. Yep. Clacky balls. Made it back. Little the office Easter egg there.
不，并没有。一大套碰撞球。嗯哼。哇。是的。碰撞球。又出现了。办公室的一个彩蛋。
Well, listen, on that note, I think we should take a break because when we come back, we're going to talk about what is my favorite scene in this whole episode. Awesome. All right, we are back, and we're going into, I think, you and I's favorite scene of the whole episode, lady. Yes, it's Travis and Detrick. They've gone to meet with the assistant fish and game warden to talk about this new fishing law. Yeah. And Travis, you know, as they arrive, he's putting on a blazer over his softies t-shirt. He's clearly wanting to look a little bit nicer.
好吧，听着，顺便说一句，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我们要聊聊整集中我最喜欢的一场戏。太棒了。好的，我们回来了，我们要进入，我想是你和我整集中最喜欢的一场戏，女士。是的，那是特拉维斯和迪特里克。他们去见助理渔猎监督官，谈论这个新的捕鱼法。是的。然后特拉维斯，你知道的，当他们到达时，他在他的Softies T恤外面套了一件西装外套。他显然想让自己看起来稍微体面一点。
And we find out that the assistant fish and game warden is Harper Brewster. his ex-girlfriend, I love this scene so much, it's perfection. Please tell me you pulled an audio clip. I absolutely did. And I want to give a shout out as you listen to Tani Newsom, who plays Harper, Detrick, played by Melvin Gregg, and Matt Peters, who plays Gary. They are so damn funny in it. Let's hear it. Mr. Moore?
然后我们发现助理渔猎监督官是哈珀·布鲁斯特。他的前女友，我太喜欢这场戏了，简直完美。求求你告诉我你剪辑了一段音频。我绝对剪了。在你们听的时候，我要向扮演哈珀的塔妮·纽瑟姆（Tani Newsom）、扮演迪特里克的梅尔文·格雷格（Melvin Gregg）以及扮演加里的马特·皮特斯（Matt Peters）致敬。他们在里面的表演太搞笑。我们来听听。莫尔先生？
Yes, Assistant Fishing Game Ward and Brewster, right? Travis? Hello, Harper. How are you? You know you're not supposed to be here. I'm here in my official capacity as a reporter, okay? Not your ex-boyfriend. You have to respect me as a member of the press, all right?
是的，助理渔猎监督官布鲁斯特，对吧？特拉维斯？你好，哈珀。你好吗？你知道你不该来这里的。我是以记者这一官方身份来的，好吗？不是你的前男友。你必须把我当作媒体的一员来尊重，好吗？
The First Amendment compels you. Everything okay here? What's up, Gary? I'm with Gary now, Travis. I'm just here to ask you guys some questions about fish. That's it. I warn you what would happen. Now have to tune you up.
宪法第一修正案迫使你这么做。这里一切都好吗？怎么了，加里？我现在和加里在一起，特拉维斯。我来这儿只是想问你们几个关于鱼的问题。就这样。我警告过你会有什么下场。现在得修理你一下了。
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold a second, Gary. Okay, look, we're just here's reporters. We have one question, one question, and we'll leave, right? Yeah. Has the Blue Gill limit in the Lake Erie District changed recently? You know that it has. What are we doing? That's great, thank you.
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等一下，加里。好吧，听着，我们只是作为记者来这里的。我们有一个问题，就一个问题，然后我们就走，对吧？对。伊利诺伊湖区的蓝鳃太阳鱼捕捞限制最近改变了吗？你知道它已经变了。我们在干什么？太好了，谢谢。
We're done. That was a setup question, Gary. I obviously need to ask a follow-up. Go, yes. Thank you. Follow-up. Harper, is there any part of you that still loves me? Dude, I warned you.
我们谈完了。那是道诱导题，加里。我显然需要问一个后续问题。去吧，是的。谢谢。后续问题。哈珀，你内心深处还有一点点爱我吗？老兄，我警告过你了。
Follow up to that. This is the guy that you chose? Are you kidding me? Get out. Get out. Oh, ow, ow, my foot. I mean, it's so good. It's so good.
对此的后续问题。这就是你选择的男人？你在开玩笑吗？滚。滚开。噢，哦，哦，我的脚。我的意思是，太棒了。太棒了。
That was a setup question. Clearly I have a follow-up. up. I really love this scene. I wanted to know if we were going to see more of the characters of Harper and Gary. I went to IMDB. This is the only episode that Tani and Matt are listed in as guest stars. Greg, Michael, if you are listening, can we please revisit this love triangle in season two? Because I know you're working on season two right now. Yes, if you're listening, we want more of this love triangle. I loved it so much. So much. All right. Now we are back at the Toledo Truth Teller offices, and Nicole is working on her letter from the editor, even though she's not the editor.
那是道诱导题。我显然有一个后续问题。我真的很喜欢这场戏。我很想知道我们是否会看到更多关于哈珀和加里的角色。我去查了IMDB。这是唯一一集塔妮和马特作为客串明星被列入名单的剧集。格雷格、迈克尔，如果你们在听，我们能在第二季中再次审视这个三角恋吗？因为我知道你们现在正在制作第二季。是的，如果你们在听，我们想要更多这样的三角恋。我太喜欢了。太喜欢了。好的。现在我们回到了托莱多真话报办公室，妮可正在写她的主编寄语，尽管她不是主编。
Mm-hmm. And Esmeralda is going to come by her desk, see what she's doing, and, you know, she's a saboteur. Yeah, she's the second shi-stir of this episode. Oh, okay. She's going to tell Nicole, I need you to defrost the freezer right now. You are the only person who can do this task. I have a question. Yeah.
嗯哼。埃斯梅拉达走到她的办公桌旁，看她在做什么，而且，你知道的，她是个破坏分子。是的，她是这一集的第二个搅屎棍。噢，好吧。她要告诉妮可，我需要你现在就把冰箱化霜。你是唯一能做这件事的人。我有个问题。是的。
Who is the boss of this office? Why is Esmerelda allowed to redirect what Nicole is doing? Because I thought Asmeralda, she's in charge of online content. She's the online newspaper. But Ned is in charge of the print newspaper and is sort of like the boss of the office. But are they like co-bosses? I don't think they're co-bosses, but I think – I think Esmeralda is senior to Nicole and has probably been her boss in some form for so long.
这个办公室的老大到底是谁？为什么埃斯梅拉达可以对妮可正在做的事情指手画脚？因为我以为阿斯梅拉达负责的是网络内容。她是网络报纸的负责人。但内德负责纸质报纸，有点像办公室的老大。但他们算不算联合老大？我觉得他们不算联合老大，但我认为——我认为埃斯梅拉达的资历比妮可老，而且在某种程度上当了她这么久的上司，
that she still bosses her around a little bit, but probably this is not someone that Nicole has to listen to anymore. But it's just sort of like learned behavior. Well, it sounds like this job of defrosting the freezer has happened before as well. Yeah. Nicole has had this job before. Esmeralda might just boss Nicole around. That might be their dynamic. I had a question. Do they need a new freezer? I mean, how often do you defrost your freezer? Yes. Here's my follow up to that. I don't think they have the money for a new freezer. I guess you're right.
以至于她现在还是会对妮可指手画脚，但可能妮可已经不用再听她的了。不过这有点像是一种条件反射式的习惯。好吧，听起来清理冰箱这件苦差事以前也发生过。对啊。妮可以前就干过这活儿。埃斯梅拉达可能就是喜欢对妮可呼来喝去。这可能就是他们的相处模式。我有个问题。他们是不是需要一个新冰箱？我是说，你们多久清理一次冰箱？对。我接着想问的是。我觉得他们没有钱买新冰箱。我想你说得对。
Well, when Nicole gets up to go defrost this terrible freezer, Esmeralda sits down in Nicole's computer and starts typing out this letter from the editor. So now Esmeralda's writing it. You're going to find out it's not going to be a great letter. Right. Saboteur. Saboteur. Meanwhile, Ned is on the phone.
好了，当妮可起身去清理这个可怕的冰箱时，埃斯梅拉达坐到了妮可的电脑前，开始打这封主编致辞。所以现在是埃斯梅拉达在写了。你们一会儿就会发现，这信写得不会太好。没错。搞破坏的人。搞破坏的人。与此同时，内德正在打电话。
He's desperately trying to find if there's any crime in the area. He's not having any luck. He's very frustrated. He calls the morgue. He's like, are you sure? Can you look in any of the drawers? Yeah, he's like, have any new bodies come in? Yeah.
他拼命想打听附近有没有发生什么犯罪案件。他一点运气也没有。他非常沮丧。他给太平间打电话，说，你们确定吗？你们能找找任何抽屉吗？对，他说，有送来什么新尸体吗？对。
Are you sure no new bodies have come in? Have you looked everywhere? Yeah. It's weird. It's creepy. But he's desperate. Did you clock how orange his fingers are getting? I literally wrote down, Popcorn Tracker.
你们确定没有新尸体送来吗？你们每个地方都找过了吗？对。这太奇怪了。太诡异了。但他急疯了。你们注意到他的手指变得有多橙了吗？我直接写下了：爆米花追踪器。
He's eating the cheese popcorn now and his fingers are orange. So yes, I did. I thought it was such a great touch. It just kind of reminded me of when we got the kids Cheetos on this car ride. We took a road trip. Oh, no. In the back seat, like the window is like just like orange dust everywhere. Mm-hmm.
他现在在吃芝士爆米花，手指都变橙了。所以，是的，我注意到了。我觉得这个细节太棒了。它让我想起我们在车上给孩子们买奇多零食的时候。我们进行了一次公路旅行。哦，不。后座上，就像车窗上到处都是橙色的粉末。嗯。
Mm-hmm. Well, Esmeralda's going to pop her head into Ned's office and be like, I'm excited for our lunch. And Ned is like, I can't do lunch. And she's like, oh, no, I invited Marv. It's your welcome lunch. And Ned's like, fine, fine. He can't say no to Marv. No.
嗯。好了，埃斯梅拉达把头探进内德的办公室说，我很期待我们的午餐。内德却说，我不能去吃午餐。她说，哦，不，我邀请了马尔夫。这是你的欢迎午餐。内德说，好吧，好吧。他没法拒绝马尔夫。不。
That's the boss boss. Yes. He's like, I'll go to lunch, but it needs to be quick. And as Marilda says, you know, in Italy, we have a saying, If a man eats quick, he also finishes quick. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And then she sachets out.
那是真正的老大。是的。他说，我去吃午餐，但得快点。埃斯梅拉达说，你知道的，在意大利，我们有一句俗语，如果一个男人吃得快，他结束得也快。嗯。对。然后她扭着腰走了出去。
She does. God, I love her. She's got some really great one-liners. She really does. Well, now at the lunch, Esmeralda is trying to sabotage him, but it's backfiring. For example, she says, you know, Ned got rid of the wire. That was his idea, you know? And they're like, great.
她确实走了。天哪，我太喜欢她了。她有一些非常棒的台词。她真的很有才。好了，现在到了午餐时间，埃斯梅拉达正试图破坏他的计划，但结果适得其反。例如，她说，你知道，内德把合众国际社的专线取消了。那是他的主意，你知道的？他们说，太棒了。
Take some balls. Yes. She's also trying to make this lunch last as long as possible. possible. So we find out she sent her fish back like three times. Yeah. Because she's trying to make it so that he can't get his paper done today. She's also ordered wine. Mm-hmm. This restaurant that they're eating in, I recognized it and I'm really proud of myself. Really? Yes. I was pretty sure when I saw it that I had shot something there before. Where is it? It's a faky restaurant on the universal lot. This was my suspicion. I'm like, I have shot here. So I reached out to Kelly Cantley, first AD. And guess what? I was
真有种。是的。她还试图让这顿午餐持续尽可能长的时间。所以我们发现她把她的鱼退了大概三次。对。因为她想让他今天没法把报纸搞定。她还点酒。嗯。他们吃饭的这家餐厅，我认出来了，我为自己感到骄傲。真的吗？是的。我看到它的时候就挺确凿地确认为我在那儿拍过东西。在哪儿？那是环球影城外景地的一个假餐厅。这是我的猜测。我在想：我在那儿拍过戏。所以我联系了第一助理导演凯利·坎特利。你猜怎么着？我
right. I was right. What is it? She said we shot the restaurant on the New York Street on the universal back lot. Oh, I know the New York Street. Yes. Yeah. Now here's the thing. When you shoot in a faky restaurant, you have to create all of the business outside of the windows. And this faky restaurant has windows on two sides. So if you watch this scene, not only do you have to fill the restaurant with all the people inside, you have to make all the business happen outside. So you have to watch this because it's really, really cool. You see cars driving by. You see pedestrians. All this is happening. I asked Kelly about it. She said we had 24 background performers inside the restaurant and 40 people outside the restaurant.
猜对了。我猜对了。那是哪儿？她说我们在环球影城外景地的纽约街拍摄了这家餐厅。哦，我知道纽约街。是的。对。现在问题来了。当你在一个假餐厅拍摄时，你必须在窗户外面创造所有的生活气息。而且这个假餐厅两面都有窗户。所以如果你看这场戏，你不仅得让餐厅里面挤满各种各样的人，还得让外面发生所有的生活琐事。所以你一定要看这场戏，因为它真的、真的太酷了。你能看到汽车开过去。你能看到行人。所有这些都在发生。我问过凯利这件事。她说我们在餐厅里面有24名背景演员，餐厅外面有40个人。
20 people were drivers and 20 people were pedestrians who were like parking cars or walking by. She said, Joe Moore, who was their second, second AD, and Elizabeth Robbins, their DGA trainee, and nine production assistants, had to help with all of the traffic direction,
20个人是司机，20个人是行人，他们负责停车或走过。她说，乔·摩尔，他们的第二副导演，伊丽莎白·罗宾斯，他们的DGA（导演工会）练习生，以及九名制片助理，都必须协助处理所有的交通疏导，
and she sent me the map that shows the loop that the cars made. And it reminded me of, the proposal scene that John and I did. I was going to say, look at all of that sort of atmosphere and ambiance and background. They had to create out of nothing. Yes. So when you watch this restaurant scene, just know it is all actors.
她给我发了地图，上面显示了汽车行驶的环形路线。这让我想起了约翰和我拍的求婚那场戏。我正想说，看看所有那种气氛、氛围和背景。他们不得不凭空创造出来。是的。所以当你观看这场餐厅戏时，要知道那全都是演员。
Very good, right? So good. And all the work that went into that one moment. Also, at the end of this restaurant scene, did you see how Ned eats his cupcake? Yes. He's running out. He got a cupcake somehow. And he pulls the bottom off of the cupcake.
非常棒，对吧？太棒了。为了那一刻付出了所有的努力。另外，在这场餐厅戏的结尾，你看到内德是怎么吃他的纸杯蛋糕的吗？看到了。他快跑出来了。他不知从哪儿弄来了一个纸杯蛋糕。他把纸杯蛋糕的底部撕下来。
Yeah. And then he puts it on the top and he makes like a little cupcake sandwich. Yeah. And the peacock version, Marv thinks that the way he ate his cupcake is like visionary. And that just annoys the hell out of Esmeralda. That's how I eat my cupcakes. Are you serious? Yes.
对。然后他把它放到顶部，弄成了一个小纸杯蛋糕三明治。对。而在孔雀网版本里，马尔夫觉得他吃纸杯蛋糕的方式简直具有远见。这把埃斯梅拉达气个半死。我吃纸杯蛋糕就是这样的。你是说真的吗？是的。
Mm-hmm. Why? If I'm on the go. Because, you know why? Because I don't like to like have to like smooosh all. all the icing into my upper lip and bottom of my nose, which is what happens when you eat a cupcake. Yeah.
嗯。为什么？如果我在赶时间的话。因为，你知道为什么吗？因为我不想把所有的糖霜都弄到我的上唇和鼻子底下，吃纸杯蛋糕的时候经常会这样。对。
But if you smush it down and eat it like a little cupcake sandwich. Like a ding-dong. Yes. Mm-hmm. Then you get the icing right where you want it. We've talked about so much snack food in this episode. What is happening? I don't know, but now I'm hungry.
但如果你把它压扁，像吃一个小纸杯蛋糕三明治那样吃。像丁东蛋糕一样。是的。嗯。那你就能把糖霜弄到你想要的地方。我们在这一集里聊了好多零食。这到底是怎么回事？我不知道，但我现在饿了。
Well, now we're going to go to Adelola and Adam, who are at the dog park. they're still trying to find some story. The parking thing is a bust, but they're like, let's ask these teenagers if there's anything happening around town. And the teenagers immediately just mess with them. They say that there's a thing called dogging where they just act like dogs when they get together and hang out. And they like bark.
好了，现在我们要去找阿德洛拉和亚当，他们在狗公园。他们还在努力找什么新闻线索。停车那件事泡汤了，但他们想，让我们问问这些青少年，城里有没有发生什么事。而这些青少年立刻就捉弄起他们来。他们说有一种叫“学狗叫（dogging）”的东西，就是他们聚在一起闲逛时表现得像狗一样。他们还会汪汪叫。
And I can't believe Adelola and Adam think this is a thing. Well, I'm going to come to their defense. Okay. First of all, I want to give a guest star shout out to the teenagers. who were played by Jillian Craighead and Zaire Adams. But here is me coming to the defense of this storyline. Okay. Is the idea of Doggin any less realistic than 6-7?
我简直不敢相信阿德洛拉和亚当会把这当真。好吧，我要为他们辩护。好的。首先，我要向客串出演这些青少年的演员致谢，他们是吉莉安·克雷格黑德和扎伊尔·亚当斯。但接下来我要为这个剧情辩护。好的。“学狗叫”这个概念比“6-7”更不现实吗？
Oh, yeah, 6-7 makes everyone go berserk. 6-7 is like so random. It makes no sense to me. It has no meaning. It's not meant to make sense. Right. So who's to say that, kids aren't barking at each other and calling it dog.
哦，是的，6-7让所有人都陷入疯狂。6-7太随机了。我完全无法理解。它没有任何意义。它本来就不是为了讲道理的。对。所以谁能说孩子们不会学狗叫着互相挑逗，并把它叫做学狗叫呢？
Oh, that's true. That's true. I'm dogging you. And I remember there was like a trend. It was a few years ago where people would perch. Like they was perching. I don't know. I did it with Sarah Highland on this movie.
哦，也是。也是。我在逗你玩。我记得以前有过一个潮流。那是几年前的事了，人们会蹲着。就像他们在学猫头鹰蹲着一样。我不知道。我在这部电影里和莎拉·海兰一起做过。
You were supposed to just sit on the edge of something like an owl, like you perch. I didn't even know what I was doing. Like, I just did it because they were like, let's do this for a picture. But yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'm just saying these things do come up. Yes. I'm agreeing with you.
你本该像猫头鹰一样蹲在某种东西的边缘，就像你蹲着那样。我甚至不知道自己在干什么。就像，我只是照做，因为他们说：我们拍张照片来做这个吧。但确实。是的。我的意思是，我是说这些潮流确实会出现。是的。我同意你的观点。
Yes. I mean, we're doing trends now on TikTok, lady. What's happening? We are doing TikTok trends. Are people following us on TikTok, Office Ladies' Pod? I want you to know that we have this really young, fun team at Block Party who tells us what trends are happening and then pitches us a few. And half the time, Jen and I don't even know what we're doing, but we do them.
是的。我的意思是，女士，我们现在在TikTok上赶时髦呢。这到底是怎么回事？我们确实在追TikTok热潮。大家在TikTok的“Office Ladies”播客上关注我们了吗？我想让你们知道，我们在派对街（Block Party）有一支非常年轻、有趣的团队，他们会告诉我们现在流行什么趋势，然后给我们提几个建议。有一半时间，我和珍甚至不知道自己在干什么，但我们还是照做了。
Lady, you just sent me one. I did. You want to do that thing where one of us holds the other person's leg and then you try to thread through their arm. You kind of have to dive through the other person's arm while someone's holding your leg. I mean, it's going to be a hot mess. I don't know. I'm worried I'm going to get hurt. I know. We're too old for that one. That one we might have to nix. Well, as Ned is leaving, he gets this phone call. He's like really excited. He's at this lunch.
女士，你刚刚才给我发了一个。我确实发了。你想做那个动作吗：一个人抓住另一个人的腿，然后你试着从对方的手臂中间穿过去。你得从另一个人的手臂里钻过去，同时有人抓着你的腿。我的意思是，这绝对会是一团糟。我不知道。我担心我会受伤。我知道。我们对那个动作来说太老了。那个我们可能得放弃。好了，当内德离开时，他接到了这个电话。他看起来真的很兴奋。他正在吃午餐。
He gets this phone call. And guess what? The police department calls. They're like, hey, are you the guy who called earlier wondering if there were any crime stories? Because we have a possible serial killer. Yeah. And he's like, that's fantastic. And the guy's like, what? And he's I mean, it's terrible. It's clearly terrible. But now he might have a story for his paper. So he returns to the office. He's very excited.
他接到了这个电话。你猜怎么着？警察局打来的。他们说，喂，你就是之前打电话问有没有什么犯罪新闻的那个人吗？因为我们这儿有一个疑似连环杀手。对。他说，太棒了。那个人说，什么？我是说，这太可怕了。这显然很可怕。但现在他可能为他的报纸搞到一条大新闻了。于是他回到了办公室。他非常兴奋。
He tells mayor. Very close talking. She's the person he wanted to tell. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Oh, okay. Yeah. Close talking sharing.
他告诉市长。靠得非常近地说话。她就是他想告诉的那个人。嗯。嗯。哦，好吧。对。近距离说话分享。
Mm-hmm. So the two of them, they're off. They're going to, like, go try to figure this out. Yeah. Adelola and Adam come back. They're typing up their story. Oscar overhears them talking, and he says, did you guys get any questions? Did you guys get any quotes?
嗯。所以他们俩出发了。他们要去，就像去试着弄清楚这件事。对。阿德洛拉和亚当回来了。他们在打字写自己的新闻。奥斯卡无意中听到他们在谈论，他说，你们采访到什么问题了吗？你们拿到什么引语了吗？
Yep. They didn't. Oscar rolls his eyes, kind of looks to camera. Yep. Has a classic snark look to camera. Is this the first time Oscar has spoken in this episode? It is. It is.
是的。他们没有。奥斯卡翻了个白眼，有点面向镜头看去。对。带着一个经典的对镜头翻白眼的表情。这是奥斯卡在本集中第一次说话吗？是的。是的。
Yes, because from the last episode, Oscar makes it clear he doesn't want to be part of this documentary and he doesn't want to participate. Leave me out of it. Yes. But guess what? He's getting curious. He is. About being a reporter. And this is going to pay off later.
是的，因为从上一集开始，奥斯卡就明确表示他不想参与这个纪录片，他不想参与其中。别把我算进去。对。但你猜怎么着？他开始好奇了。是的。对当记者感到好奇。这在后面会有回报。
I really like how they incorporated the character of Oscar into this new show. They didn't make him front and center. Yeah. You know, he's very much a supporting character right now. Right. And I think that was really smart. So you're slowly going to see him getting more invested in the paper. Yes.
我真的很喜欢他们把奥斯卡这个角色融入到这个新节目中的方式。他们没有把他放在最显眼的位置。对。你知道，他现在很大程度上是一个配角。对。而且我觉得这真的非常明智。所以你会慢慢看到他对报纸投入更多。是的。
And it plays out over time. Yes. So Detrick returns to the office and he says, Travis has been arrested. We didn't get our fish story. But I sold an ad. The guy's trying to sell his boat. So they have one ad for the paper. That's, I think, all they have.
而且这会随着时间的推移逐渐展开。是的。所以迪特里克回到办公室说，特拉维斯被捕了。我们没有弄到我们的鱼的故事。但我卖出了一则广告。那家伙想卖掉他的船。所以他们报纸上有一则广告。我想这就是他们全部的家当了。
So far their paper is a single ad. Yeah. But ads are good. Yeah. Yeah. After Adelola and Adam give Ned their story about the dog in, Ned says, yeah, I called two local high school principals and none of this story is real. I can't print it.
到目前为止，他们的报纸只有一则广告。对。不过有广告总比没有好。对。对。在阿德洛拉和亚当把关于学狗叫的故事告诉内德之后，内德说，没错，我给当地两位高中校长打了电话，这个故事全都是假的。我没法刊登。
Nope. Mm-hmm. He does get a mystery manila envelope, though. And inside it is a Sudoku. Yes. It has like the version with all of the empty spaces, and then it has the answer. Yeah. So that's good.
不。嗯。不过他确实收到一个神秘的马尼拉纸信封。里面是一个数独。对。它有那种留出所有空白格的版本，然后还有答案。对。所以这挺好。
So now what do we have for the paper? We have the Sudoku and an ad. That's it. Mm-hmm. Because guess what? Nicole finally returns to her desk. She sees the letter from the editor written by Esmeralda, and it's just basically a letter from Ned's point of view saying that he stole this job from a woman named Esmeralda who has a
那现在我们的报纸有什么内容？我们有一个数独和一则广告。就这些。嗯。因为你猜怎么着？妮可终于回到她的办公桌前。她看到了埃斯梅拉达写的“主编致辞”，那基本上就是一封从内德的角度写的信，说他从一个名叫埃斯梅拉达的女人手里抢走了这份工作，
bang and body, despite being a single mother. It's just all about Esmeralda and her awesome body. Yeah, and how he took her job. So clearly, they can't use that. No, so Nicole just deletes it. Mare is going to have a talking head where she says, it's 538, and she doesn't know what they're going to print. Maybe she'll just type up the train schedules to be safe. And lady, this made me curious. What? I was curious about the 6 p.m. deadline that they're up against. And then I started researching what the hours are like to get a newspaper out into the world. And I found this fantastic YouTube video about a local newspaper in Singapore called The Straits Times. And they sort of take you through their night getting a newspaper out. It starts at 5.30 p.m. And all throughout the night,
她虽然是个单亲妈妈，却有着火辣的身材。信里全都是关于埃斯梅拉达和她那迷人的身材。对，还有他是怎么抢了她的工作。所以很显然，他们不能用这个。不，于是妮可直接把它删了。玛尔将有一个访谈镜头，她说，现在是5点38分，她不知道他们要印刷什么。也许她干脆把火车时刻表打上去以防万一。女士，这让我很好奇。什么？我对他们正在面临的下午6点截稿时间很好奇。然后我开始研究把一份报纸出版发行到底需要什么样的工作时间。我找到了一个关于新加坡当地一家名为《海峡时报》的报社的精彩YouTube视频。他们带你了解了他们出版一份报纸的整个夜晚。从下午5点30分开始。整整一夜，
different articles and headlines are coming together and they're printing. And their day ends at 5.30 a.m. So whoever Ned is turning this over to is going to be the night shift that is then going to get this newspaper out by daybreak. Wow. It's a really interesting existence. Like, the man that was showing you around the newspaper in Singapore said, you know, his wife is leaving for work when he's getting home. Yeah.
不同的文章和头条新闻逐渐汇集在一起，然后他们开始印刷。他们的一天在清晨5点30分结束。所以内德接下来要把这摊子事交接给的人，将是夜班人员，他们将在天亮前把这份报纸出版。哇。这真是一种有趣的生活方式。就像那个带你参观新加坡报社的人说的，你知道，当他到家时，他的妻子正要出门去上班。对。
Yeah. So shout out to the night shift at the newspaper. Yes, thank you. Well, guess what? Their final article, the one thing they thought they still had, this crime beat article, is also going to fall apart. Yeah. Because what they realize is that the morgue,
对。所以向报社的夜班人员致敬。是的，谢谢。好吧，你猜怎么着？他们的最后一篇文章，他们以为他们还留着的唯一东西——这篇犯罪突发新闻文章——也要泡汤了。对。因为他们意识到太平间
called the police to say that some creep called them, insisting that there was a body they didn't know about and they needed to look around for it. And we realized it was Ned. Yeah, Ned's really quickly, like, hangs up because he's like, oh, crap. Ned's like, oh, no. So there's no serial killer. There's no nothing. So Ned has to quickly bang out a letter from the editor. And he decides to title it, no news is good news. Mm-hmm. And he says that's not something you expect. to hear from the editor-in-chief of the town newspaper, but a lack of crime is evidence of people who treasure their community. And so he releases this very long letter, which in order to pat it,
给警察打电话说，有个怪人打电话给他们，坚称有一具他们不知道的尸体，他们需要到处找找。然后我们意识到那是内德。对，内德非常迅速地挂断了电话，因为他想，哦，糟糕。内德心想：哦，不。所以根本没有连环杀手。什么都没有。所以内德不得不赶快拼凑出一封主编致辞。他决定把标题定为：没有新闻就是好消息。嗯。他说这不是你从镇上报纸的主编那里期待听到的话，但没有犯罪正是人们珍视自己社区的证明。于是他发表了这篇极长的致辞，为了凑字数，
he just ends up kind of plagiarizing. Yeah. Elmore Leonard's novels. Fifty-two pickup. He just includes a few chapters of it, it sounds like. Yes, and get shorty. Yeah. There is a great cutaway. It's Oscar. He's outside. He's at the newspaper stand. He's picking up the paper, and he's really excited to see the Sudoku puzzle because he created it. Yes, we didn't know who did it, but it's revealed it was Oscar. And Oscar calls Stanley, and is like, Stanley, what'd you think? Yeah, he sends him a picture of it. And he's like, oh, you would say it's too easy, Stanley, of course.
他最后基本上就是抄袭了埃尔默·伦纳德的小说。是的。比如《52号百叶窗》。听起来他直接把人家好几章给搬进去了。没错，还有《矮子当道》。对。有一个很棒的切换镜头。是奥斯卡。他在外面。在报摊前。他正在拿报纸，看到数独谜题时特别兴奋，因为那是他自己设计的。对，以前我们不知道是谁做的，但现在揭晓了，原来是奥斯卡。然后奥斯卡给斯坦利打电话，问，斯坦利，你觉得怎么样？对，他还给他发了张照片。并且说，哦，你肯定会说这太简单了，斯坦利，当然了。
It's a very cute exchange, and it shows that Oscar's still in touch with Stanley. Yeah, and it may be hints to the fact that Oscar is still in touch with other people. from Dunder Mifflin. Yes. Well, the episode is going to end with a mare talking head. She says, you know, it wasn't perfect, but it was his first issue. And she framed it, and she put it in the hallway next to the other antiques. It's very, very sweet.
这是一次非常可爱的互动，它表明奥斯卡和斯坦利仍然保持着联系。是的，这也可能暗示了奥斯卡与其他邓德米弗林的人也依然保持着联系。没错。好了，这一集最后以梅尔的访谈镜头结束。她说，你知道，这虽然不够完美，但这是他的第一期报纸。她把报纸装裱起来，挂在了走廊里，紧挨着其他古董旁边。非常非常温馨。
Yeah. Well, you know, this episode was directed by Ken Quappas, and we did reach out to him because I wanted to know what was it like to return to the world of mockumentary, and did you have any challenges? He wrote us back such a lovely email. He did. I remembered something that Greg told us when we visited. He said, when we designed this space, we wanted it to look very different from Dunder Mifflin. And they also researched what these old newspaper buildings looked like.
对。话说回来，这一集是由肯·夸皮斯执导的，我们确实联系了他，因为我想知道重返伪纪录片世界是什么感觉，有什么挑战吗？他给我们回了一封非常亲切的邮件。确实如此。我还记得格雷格去探班时告诉过我们的一件事。他说，我们在设计这个空间时，就希望它看起来和邓德米弗林非常不一样。而且他们还专门去研究了那些老报社大楼长什么样。
And they were big and expansive. And beautiful old grand buildings with the big windows. Yes. So they have this giant bullpen, which Ken Kopp is said is so different from the Dundra Mifflin bullpen. He said it was a challenge to visually connect. people in the space. He said he was very grateful that this opened with a conference room scene because he could get everybody in the same room and really tell the story of who people were and connect them. And he certainly has a lot of experience with conference room scenes.
它们既宽敞又巨大。而且是美丽宏伟的老建筑，配有大窗户。是的。所以这里有一个巨大的开放式办公区，肯·夸皮斯说这和邓德米弗林的开放式办公区太不一样了。他说，要在视觉上把空间里的人联系起来是一个挑战。他非常感激这一集是以会议室场景开场的，因为这样他就能把所有人聚在同一个房间里，真正讲好每个人是谁的故事，并将他们联系起来。而且他在拍摄会议室场景方面确实经验丰富。
But he also confirmed what Greg said, which was spy shots were difficult because when they were designing the set, the set was designed by Susie Mancini, by the way. And Greg said, I want you to use different blinds. Yeah. Because I don't want it to look like. under Mifflin. So they chose these, like, tinier blinds. But then when you open them, it's really hard to do spy shots through them. Yeah. The blinds being a bigger size was a good thing. Yes. But overall, Ken was just so happy to be back working with these people. He said it's an amazing group of actors. And he had a great time. Well, I love that Ken is part of this world, too, and I love seeing all the little crossover moments. But I'm excited to get to know these characters.
但他也证实了格雷格说过的话，那就是偷窥视角（镜头）很难拍，因为在设计布景时——顺便说一句，布景是由苏西·曼奇尼设计的。格雷格说，我希望你们用不同的百叶窗。对。因为我不想让它看起来像邓德米弗林。所以他们选了这种比较小的百叶窗。但当你打开它们时，很难透过它们拍到偷窥镜头。是的。百叶窗尺寸大一点确实有好处。对。不过总的来说，肯能回来和这些人一起工作感到非常高兴。他说这是一个了不起的演员团队。他度过了一段美好的时光。嗯，我也很高兴肯能成为这个世界的一部分，也很喜欢看到所有这些小彩蛋时刻。但我更期待去了解这些角色。
Yeah, I agree. Well, listen, everybody, that's your breakdown of the paper episode two. A big thank you to Kelly Cantley, Ken Quapis, Chelsea Frye, and Scott McGuinness, the Prop Master. Thanks for answering our questions when we reached out, and we'll see you guys all next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerk,
对，我同意。好了，各位听众，这就是《纸业公司》第二集的解析。非常感谢凯利·坎特利、肯·夸皮斯、切尔西·弗莱以及道具师斯科特·麦吉尼斯。感谢你们在收到我们的联系时回答了我们的问题，我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audacy的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰克，
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audacy的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。